we'll call this meeting of the house
judiciary committee to order
and to begin i will call upon
representative langley and asked her if
she would lead us in the pledge of
allegiance
allegiance to the flag of the united
states of america and to the republic
for which it stands
one nation under god
indivisible with liberty and justice for
all
thank
you mr clerk would you be willing to
call the role
i am willing and able representative
gordon here
representative welper is here
representative alexander representative
greene
representative notter
representative merner
representative kelly
representative trottier
representative andrus
representative marjorie smith
representative burch
representative horrigan
representative dilorenzo
representative chase
representative kenny
representative langley representative
macbeth
representative page
representative simpson i know this
representative horrigan just walked in
where's your name it's right there
two four six eight ten on business
chairman thank you
thank you mr clerk our first item in uh
business this morning is a hearing on
that is a bill permitting arraignments
for felonies and preliminary
examinations to be heard in the circuit
court
i am the primary sponsor i'm going to
call upon representative greene to see
chair you got a whole bunch here
it's all
i'm sorry
okay i'll go from the top then
all right
oh obviously starting out i recognize
the prime sponsor of the bill 1597
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee
for the record my name is ned gordon and
i have the honor representing grafton
county district 9 which are the towns of
alexandria ashland bridgewater
bridgewater
bristol and grafton
and i'm bringing before you today house
bill 1597.
what this bill simply does is to require
the defendants charged with felony
offenses
be arraigned in the circuit court
and that they be entitled to a probable
cause hearing
also known as a preliminary examination
this is a subject which may be familiar
to
many of you those who have served
multiple terms here in the legislature
up until 2016
felony arraignments people who were
arrested for felonies
were
arraigned in the circuit court
and had their probable causes in the
circuit court
in 2015
the legislature passed senate bill 124.
this bill was dubbed felonies first
and it provided that the superior court
would have sold jurisdiction over felony
cases
the bill provided that all felony
arraignments were to be held in the
superior court
and instead of defendants being
automatically uh scheduled and this uh
they no longer were entitled to a
probable cause hearing
the
burden of proof was shifted to the
defendant
the defendant had to ask for the hearing
and there
and the defendant had to show there was
some defect in the charging in order to
be entitled to one
and ultimately the court the superior
court had the discretion to grant or
deny the request for a probable cause
hearing
the uh the bill uh house senate bill 124
was very well intended the purpose was
to vertically integrate felony
arraignments into the superior court
which seemed to make a lot of sense and
it would seem to improve court
efficiency
it was expected and this is a quote from
the time
eliminate unnecessary delay and create
better outcomes for victims and
defendants and to quote
and i certainly believe that the theory
was reasonable
and it was done with the best of
intentions
but despite all the good intentions
it does not appear that the program has
been as successful as intended
and house bill 1597
at least at this time would put felony
arraignments
back into the circuit court and provide
defendants with the right to a probable
cause hearing
when the change happened i was a circuit
court judge and my life was very
different then than it is now
when
felonies moved out of the circuit court
my life became a lot easier as a circuit
court judge
no more arraignments for felonies and
their related charges
and no more probable cause hearings
but my perspective on the issue has
changed in the last few years
the time for resolution on felony cases
has improved
there are probably lots of reasons for
that but to the extent it was believed
that
taking the felony arraignments and
putting them in the superior court
reduced the time of resolution for
felony cases has not proven to be the
case
the driving uh the driving concept
between felony first was what was called
early case resolution
which makes a lot of sense dealing with
the case and trying to resolve it
earlier in the process
the real change caused by felony first
was the shift
from local police to the county
attorneys
for charging decisions and for plea
negotiations
this has been costly for the counties
who have all bulked up their uh had to i
shouldn't say bulked up but
all had to add additional staff in order
to accommodate felonies first
early case resolution has been somewhat
successful
but has not fulfilled its promise
in i know that at the time at least by
the testimony that i read back
that early case resolution was already
happening in one county
in stratford county
prior to this and was successful in
stratford county
it it that success not hasn't
necessarily
been transferred to all counties in this
case
in seeking uh
and seeking a reason why felony first
hasn't been
uh as successful or early case
resolution hasn't been successful
what i found in in doing my research for
this build is there's a lot of finger
pointing
there's a lot of finger pointing
which in some cases points to county
attorneys in some cases points to public
defenders
in some cases points to the court
but again just lots
of finger pointing
in talking to one county attorney
it was said that we can't go back to
having police departments do
arraignments
early involvement of the county attorney
is critically important
and i absolutely agree with that
but now that
there has been additional staff added in
each of the counties
there's no reason why the county can't
be more involved in early case
resolution
even if the arraignments are done in the
it isn't as if
we have to turn the clock back
and make that type of change we can
improve the system
and you can and in fact that was what
was happening down in stratford county
they were doing early case resolution
even when the arraignments were done in
the circuit court
there's no reason
again why county attorneys cannot be
involved in charging decisions if
arraignments are held in the circuit
court
there's been an extra burden placed on
the public defender system which is
already overburdened and understaffed
the judicial council is currently
finding it difficult to obtain
representation for felony defendants
without probable cause hearings case
there's uh
a
sub
i think a point that i'd like to make is
that there's a substantial difference
between probable cause hearings and
early case resolution
you would think that they would be
similar
but in the legislature we know that
things get done here in the legislature
when you have deadlines
the the difference between a probable
cause hearing and early case resolution
is that one has a consequence and the
other doesn't
when you have a probable cause hearing
a defendant has to make a choice
are they going to enter into some type
of resolution or are they going to be
bound over there's a consequence to that
decision
if you really have early case resolution
basically you have a conference
i was talking to a public a public
defender who said
this is affecting uh my relationship
with my clients
and he said particularly the push
because the county attorneys are pushing
me pushing me pushing me to
end to have my client plea to have my
client plead to have my client plea
i can't develop a relationship with my
client if the only thing i'm asking my
client to do is enter a plea i have to
have some type of relationship and what
happens with the probable cause hearing
is there's a reason that we have to act
the defendant has to act and it's not
because i'm demanding that he enter a
plea
prior to i'm told that prior to
uh prior to
uh when when probable cause hearings
were still heard in the
circuit court
11 of the cases were resolved at or
before the probable cause hearing
with pleas
that never ended up going to the
superior court or being bound over to
the superior court
which is a substantial portion of the
burden
because of felonies first the superior
court is handling many cases that it
would not have handled in the past
and
because when you have a felony felonies
usually are accompanied by misdemeanors
and violation level offenses
and now those offenses which were
previously disposed of in the circuit
court
are now being handled by superior court
judges
which is adding to the volume of the
work that they're doing in the superior
court
and again creating that additional
burden
i think
some of the blame i think you probably
hear some of the blame can be accorded
to covid
and certainly in terms of court
scheduling i think that that is the case
but it was interesting
i went back and i read the report the
the judicial council was required to
back
when only three counties had adopted
felonies first to see how it was working
out
and if you go back and read that report
as i did last night you'll see that
these same types of issues
were addressed in that report with the
hope that they would work out the bugs
but i don't think that they have
entirely worked out the bugs and i don't
believe that the problem is just
covered
we have a long history in the state of
assuring people's rights by holding
probable cause hearings
i'm told that there's no constitutional
requirement for a probable cause hearing
and i'm sure that's the case
but if a person is threatened by the
state with at least a year in jail
it seems to me that it's fair to require
the state to show that there's a
reasonable basis for bringing the charge
i understand court efficiency
but i don't think it should be at the
expense of fairness
even if we do not reinstate an automatic
probable cause hearing
one should be made made available to all
defendants upon demand and they should
not have to prove that there's some
defect in the charging before they're
entitled to have one
finally when i was in the legislature
many years ago we were approached with
what seemed like a reasonable plan
it was to take some jury trials which
were ordinarily held in the superior
the legislation passed and the court
system implemented it
it converted court rooms around the
state to include jury boxes
and there were jury trials held in the
circuit court
but frankly it just didn't work out
circuit court wasn't the place to hold
jury trials
and
and what we did was we rescinded that we
indicated that it just didn't work out
it was a mistake
and we fixed it
sometimes what seems like a good idea
just doesn't work out
and we ought to be able to acknowledge
finally again as a personal observation
there's a difference in the cultures
between the superior court and the
circuit court
the circuit court handles high case
volumes
the circuit court has a has a hectic
pace
and it has a get it done culture
the superior court has a very different
culture
and a much different pace
it's far more methodical
the circuit court is a community court
one of the advantages of being able to
have arraignments in the circuit court
is that you can triage cases
we've tried to develop specialized
courts
for veterans
for mental health issues for substance
abuse issues
the circuit court judges are familiar
with the people in their community
they're able to do that triage
instead of somebody just showing up in
the superior court for a felony
a circuit court judge can make a
determination
of what is best for that and what the
history of a particular defendant might
be
holding arraignments and and
in the circuit court i believe is more
consistent with the character and
that's my testimony
and
thank you very much for your
consideration
seeing none thank you very much
oh yes i am sorry yes no no quite a
question of you i cannot uh address this
because i'm a sponsor but i want to know
if
uh chairman gordon has copies of his
testimony available for the committee
i don't have copies for everyone on the
committee but i do can provide you with
i just this is sort of one outline which
i spoke to but i will provide that to
everybody
thank you to both of you
are you a question
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question simpson yes i
couldn't see her oh that's okay yeah
behind a bunch of tears yeah yeah
um
i missed one of the points that you were
making i was um
writing and you cited the percentage of
courts i mean percentage of cases that
did not ever go over to the superior
court and i just missed what that
percentage was
uh i'm told it's 11 percent okay thank
you i think other people may testify and
say it was a higher number okay but the
number that i
that i feel confident in is eleven
percent
yeah a question from uh our clerk
representative thank you mr chair thank
i recall you referencing 70 percent
not now and somehow i'm confused as to
what the seventy percent and the eleven
i don't wrote seventy percent
i don't know where the 70 came from
representative horgan you had a question
thank you very much mr
chair and um thank you very much mr
representative gordon um
and i'm embarrassed to say that i don't
know this even though i was around as a
member of this committee back when we
were debating felonies first it's quite
a lively debate but um does this bill
just put the law back the way it was
pre-2017 or are there some changes from
how it was
back then
good question and
it effectively puts
it back the way it was prior to
the
the the purpose and
and frankly there may be some middle
ground
here and it
to uh work things out but frankly the
system isn't working right now
and it needs to be fixed
and this bill puts things back the way
they were
but if there's some other way of fixing
it that makes sense i certainly would
entertain that
thank you thank you
thank you very much for your testimony
thank you mr chair what a great
committee
next the chair will recognize randy
hawks
oh yeah microphone please
test there we go great
i'm randy hawks i'm the executive
director of the new hampshire public
defender program i'm here today in an
informational capacity
to provide a perspective that might be
of value to this committee
when sb 124 the bill that created
felonies first was being prepared
i was part of a group of prosecutors
defense attorneys judges and clerks
assembled to weigh in on that project
i believe then as i do now that the
public defender program which handles 90
percent of cases in the indigent defense
system
had an obligation to consider any
innovation that could potentially
improve the criminal justice process
everyone on the felonies first working
group agreed that the objective was to
make a system that would make felony
case processing more efficient
while incorporating fundamental tenants
that would assure the due process rights
of defendants
the objective of that bill was reduced
to a shorthand
same justice sooner
during the process leading up to sb 124
being filed i suggest i suggested that
the bill include a sunset clause in the
event that it couldn't deliver on those
promises
the idea was rejected by proponents as
being too pessimistic
nonetheless when the bill was pending i
wrote an opinion piece in the new
hampshire bar news in support of the
proposal
in that editorial i wrote that felonies
burst was a worthwhile experiment
however i also warned
we must be vigilant to ensure that it
delivers on its promises
i would note that the then chair of this
committee robert rowe
also wrote a letter to the bar news
endorsing the bill
like me chairman rowe closed his letter
with a caveat
if felonies first does not meet
expectations the law will be amended or
eliminated
new hampshire has a long history of
creative problem solving
we also have an equally long history of
being unafraid to change direction if
the initial change doesn't produce the
anticipated effect
as someone who supported felonies first
at its inception i will present an
appraisal based on data
rather than upon anecdotes that could
in reviewing data from new hampshire
public defenders case management system
one obvious shortcoming of felonies
first has been the inability to
replicate in superior court the
efficiency with which less serious
felonies were resolved in the district
court under the previous system
it's axiomatic that
low-grade felonies shouldn't take as
long to resolve as serious felonies
historically those cases were often
resolved swiftly in the local level
there's an advantage to having the
opportunity to negotiate the disposition
of such cases at the local level where
local police prosecutors in the district
courts
are familiar with the facts of a case
and they're often familiar with the
defendants involved
so they were able to make decisions
about the fair uh the fair resolution of
these cases in a relatively expeditious
manner
that element of local control was a
major factor in quickly resolving a
substantial percentage of these
low-grade felonies
that efficiency was lost when felonies
first was implemented
i looked at data on all felonies
resolved in all courts statewide from
the year prior to the implementation of
felonies first which is 2015 through
2019 between 2015 and 2019 various
district courts were sequentially
removed from the process as felonies
first was implemented in successive
counties
eventually all felonies were filed in
the superior court
between 2015 and 2019 the time required
to resolve the average felony increased
in 2015 the combined
district court and superior court
resolution of felonies averaged 20.3
weeks from open to close
i might note that there is no need to
take notes during my testimony because
i've provided the committee with 30
copies
of
of my statement and additional
supplemental uh statistical information
so that's all going to be available to
you
in 2016
felonies first implementation began with
stratfor county and cheshire county and
they were joined halfway through the
year in july by belknap county so the
total in 2016 increased to 21.2 weeks to
resolve the average felony
a year later in 2017 other counties
started implementing felonies first on a
rolling rolling basis and as they did
too there was decreased district court
involvement by 2017 the time for the
average felony resolution had increased
to 24.3 weeks
all felonies were filed in state in
superior court statewide however there
were a few stragglers of felonies that
had been filed previously that was sort
of for lack of a better term
grandfathered in into the district court
and a few of those were making their way
through the pipeline nonetheless in 2018
the time to resolve the average felony
had increased to 26.9 weeks
and by 2019 all felonies were out of the
district courts completely and were in
superior court exclusively and the time
then was up to 27.9 weeks to resolve the
average felony so we've gone from the
year before felonies first at 20.3 weeks
to
i have the data and it's included in
your statistical information
for 2020 and 2021 but because the
pandemic
slowed court operations
the data is skewed i think beyond
relevance for this discussion so i ended
the analysis in 2019.
to gauge the loss of efficiency of
district court resolutions i looked at
felonies resolved in district courts of
all counties pre-felonies first and
compared that time with felonies
resolved in the superior court of that
county
as i say i've provided the full detail
of all the district courts and all the
superior courts but i don't want to
belabor the time here by reciting it all
but i'll give you just a couple of
salient examples
the weeks from open to close for an
average felony i looked at rockingham
county in 2015.
the district courts are brentwood candia
derry hampton plaistow portsmouth and
salem
all those district courts combined
closed 37 percent of the total number of
felonies in rockingham county and they
did so in 10 weeks
the remaining ones that were resolved in
the superior court averaged 31 weeks
from open to close so as i say 37 of
felonies resolved in district court in
an average of 21 weeks quicker than
those that went to superior court
one more example merrimack county the
district courts i looked at were concord
franklin hillsborough i didn't include
the statistics from hooksett because our
office in concord and our office in
manchester both shared that court at
different times and the statistics were
a little skewed and there weren't enough
numbers to move the needle
at any rate for merrimack county all the
district courts
of
uh
852 felonies resolved by our concord
office in merrimack county in 2015
319 were resolved in district court in
an average of 13 weeks
533 were resolved in merrimack county
superior court in an average of 31 weeks
so there's a
37 percent that were resolved in the
district courts were done 18 weeks
quicker than those that were resolved in
the superior court so as you can see
just from those two examples felonies
were resolved more efficiently in the
district courts
uh as i say the
average time statewide and you can see
all the statistics in the
written portion uh in the district court
was 10.6 weeks and the average time to
resolve a felony in superior court was
so i will skip over all the
district court details that you can
review at your leisure
i also analyze closed case data from
offices around the state to determine
whether felonies first had delivered the
quote-unquote same justice as it had
promised
the objective of felonies first was that
the outcomes would generally be the same
the only difference being that they
would happen in superior court instead
of district court
in analyzing the data i looked at the
number of felony cases opened in each
office the year before felonies first
was implemented i eliminated from the
statistics any cases where new hampshire
public defender withdrew because of a
conflict of interest or because the
defendant had hired private counsel i
also removed all cases that were closed
because the client failed to appear or
was declared incompetent or was deceased
i eliminated those cases from
consideration in this analysis because
those would have happened irrespective
of whether felonies first was in place
or not they were closed
for whatever reason that i just listed
what i utilized i compiled the data only
on cases that were opened and resolved
by new hampshire public defender what i
found was the following
in the year prior to felonies first 62
percent of all felonies statewide were
resolved by a negotiated plea in which a
defendant pled to a misdemeanor or by a
disposition that was
involved some lesser resolution
now lesser resolutions a wide variety
they could include diversion having a
matter placed on file without a finding
placed on file with a finding case could
be null processed a case could be
continued to be dismissed a case could
actually be dismissed so again
prior to the implementation of felonies
for us 62 of all felonies statewide will
resolve with a misdemeanor or some
lesser resolution
by 2019 the percentage of felonies that
were resolved that way had decreased to
50 percent
so we've been unable to attain
the stated goal of same justice and
we've been unable to attain
the stated goal of justice sooner
now as someone who supported felonies
first at its inception i'm disappointed
that it was unable to deliver on those
promises those of us who were proponents
at the inception had good intentions
and we supported the plan believing that
it had the potential to benefit all
criminal justice stakeholders
but new hampshire we recognize that
sometimes the best laid plans don't work
out the way we'd hoped
so i thank the members of this committee
for your willingness to assess where we
are and your deliberate consideration of
where we go from here
thank you
thank you and any questions for the
witness
over to our left yes representative
chase
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question i am not a lawyer
i've gone to court maybe once or twice
in my life so
tell me with all of this what is the
circuit court doing now if they've had
all these
felony cases removed and is it going to
be a giant issue time wise and
scheduling if we were to revert back
uh
that would be a question i think better
addressed to someone representing the
circuit court but i will say this our
circuit courts our local courts are
extremely busy they don't handle just
criminal matters they handle family
matters they handle uh landlord tenant
every kind of thing
if there were any branch of the system
that probably deserves more support i
would say it would be the local courts
they're the people's courts as
representative gordon said that's where
a lot of business takes place and it
takes place very efficiently
would this create a huge burden no
because statistics have shown in the
past that
probable cause hearings while scheduled
i think over 90 of them are waived
because the prosecutor gets together
with a defense attorney and they often
would work out an agreement you know
things were negotiated because people
had the facts at hand and as i said
before they often knew these defendants
because they were working in the local
police department
maybe a court would be well served to
have an additional clerk to deal with
the felony first matters coming through
for scheduling purposes but as i say to
appear in front of a judge
was
as rare as hen's teeth you know many
many probable cause
hearings were scheduled but very few
actually took place because people began
to talk it was an impetus for a
discussion early on probable cause
hearings actually served as the most
effective early case resolution in my
view that the state has ever known
because what it does it gives a date
when the rubber meets the road we're
either going to have a hearing or we're
going to talk about it and negotiate it
often they'll say you know defense
attorneys are realistic people if the
facts were overwhelming if it wasn't a
case that should be negotiated in the
district court it was a very serious
matter and
the facts of the gerstein affidavit or
whatever speak for themselves that would
often be waived
but there are a substantial percentage
of those cases that
again for lack of a better term i refer
to as a low-grade or less serious or
perhaps a victimless crime where the two
parties can get together early on and
say this would be a proper disposition
of this matter that would satisfy all
stakeholders
so
representative sylvia had a question
thank you mr chairman thank you attorney
hawks for taking my question
this is a
significant bill
and a lot of details
and i think we've asked
our chairman about the
the
question is
um does this
exactly roll us back to where we were
before felonies first are there any
details that
you've seen in the bill that we should
be aware of
uh
i think the bill
you know there's always a question of
how it might be refined going forward
but the impetus of it is to revert back
simply scheduling these matters in the
district court and giving an opportunity
for the
up the uh dispositions that i've
discussed to take place
uh
might it be fine-tuned i'd leave that
i think those things are best left to
the legislature
follow up
thank you um
when we implemented this uh there was we
were
it was suggested
that there would be a savings in the uh
county corrections department for
uh
felons would be held less
a less lesser period of time and there
would be a savings there
of course there was um
costs increased at the county attorney's
office which will be ongoing
belknap county just recently approved
another attorney to help
what do you see as the financial aspect
of this
in on the counties
there are a number of assumptions made
when the bill
was presented and passed
uh
as i say
a lot of the savings were to be
attributed to a an essential
element
the success depended on which was early
case resolution that we've talked about
it really didn't other than strafford
county
the ecr program very frankly is moribund
throughout the state if it exists at all
it's not really very active
uh the promise that that would we'd see
a decrease in recidivism absolutely the
opposite we're seeing more return
customers at the public defender than
we've seen historically
as far as cost savings and and less time
in jails i don't know that is
attributable to felonies first as much
as it was for the bail reform that took
place a couple of years ago
uh
when case when case loads increase when
case laws when cases take longer to
resolve caseloads increase
the backlog in the case of course has
been exacerbated by the pandemic but in
2019 i had a meeting at the supreme
court where i warned them that
and i followed that up a month later
with a meeting with the judicial council
that felonies first was increasing the
time it took to resolve felonies and in
october of 2019 public defender program
had breached
its caseload maximum under its contract
with the state of new hampshire
i said that it was largely due to
felonies first
and there were other things to which i
can
attribute the increase in case loads but
uh
efficiencies were being lost that was my
greatest concern and the caseload crisis
that has ensued has its roots going back
when we
i
want to hearken back to one thing that
uh
representative gordon said or someone
asked a question and talked about a lot
of finger pointing
i think that allocuting fault or blame
will simply result in a circular fine
firing squad all stakeholders in this
had to be absolutely committed to its
success
and
therefore every stakeholder is partially
responsible certain assumptions were
wrong but as i say when we have an
opportunity to reassess and i think
we're going from here
i think that's a fair approach
another follow-up
thank you and thank you for taking my
further follow-up up
currently there's a lot of talk about
bail reform and i this seems to be
pretty closely associated with that
could you
well there's an opportunity the first
opportunity of course bail will be set
particularly in uh
class a and felony cases for any
defendant by a bail bondsman or by the
police officer
the arresting agency
but there's an opportunity to address
bail at a probable cause hearing
uh
as far as uh reform of the bail
statute as it was last reformed that
again is a policy question for the
legislature i'd defer i think they're
going to hear conflicting information
about that as was the case the first
time around
i would
encourage people to rely on statistical
information rather than anecdotal
information i've tried to refrain from
anecdote in my statements and i think
that last time around
when i visited some hearings on the bail
reform there was a lot of anecdotal
information that is
while not in individual cases
untrustworthy perhaps to base policy on
so
i think it's worth in that case checking
statistics
any further questions
alexis yeah representative simpson
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question
um you mentioned that there was
uh an increase in rates of recidivism
and i wondered if you wanted to or if
you could talk to whether that's
possibly causation or if that's
particularly correlation that's always a
good question i always am
a question is this a cause or is this
just a cruel out of fact
uh
i will say this when our cases
stay open longer
and people are out on bail
we have seen an increase of
new charges being filed before the
initial charges can be resolved
and that's one
one thing that causes uh
problems and again i'm not
laying this on the court system i'm not
blaming anybody the pandemic as i say
has exacerbated all problems that we've
seen but when it comes to
the simple question of it taking longer
to resolve a felony case
is longer before someone might as part
of their
condition of their sentence go into
treatment
if that final resolution is deferred
it's more likely they're going to get
arrested for uh a new possession of a
controlled drug say or commit a new
crime a property crime to support their
substance use misuse issues uh so
there's an incentive
on the part of everyone victims
defendants the court system to try to
resolve these cases more quickly
so i don't mean to imply that felonies
first causes recidivism but it merely
the aspect of it that when felonies take
longer to resolve
uh to everyone's satisfaction there's a
greater likelihood that people will find
and do we have one more question no
okay so then if no further questions and
uh thank you for your testimony thank
you very much
morning mr chair members of the
judiciary committee my name is kate
horgan i represent the new hampshire
association of counties which is all
your elected and appointed officials uh
the association did take a position in
opposition of this bill felonies first
is working very well for 70 percent of
the counties um
and their concern is if we go back
you're going to start
seeing things that you saw before under
the old system duplication of paperwork
court proceedings and hearings without
reaching a substantial
substantial resolution of the case
felonies should start with the county
attorneys rather than police prosecutors
it allows county attorneys to have
better oversight of the case and this
has contributed to better outcomes for
everyone
i will say there are several county
attorneys here so if you have questions
i would ask that you
take them with them because they can
tell you more about process and how
things are happening in their particular
counties
okay so you will not be taking any
questions or
i am happy to try but they may be better
equipped to answer questions that's no
problem all right well thank you thank
you
next the chair recognizes let's see if i
can get this right anthony
skolem brain
s-c-u-l-i-m-b
etc did an excellent job
oh thank you
uh members of the committee honorable
chair my name is anthony scullimbrini
i'm here testifying in support of hb1597
i'm here on my own i
run a law firm in nashua at gillan
skullenbrini and i'm also here on behalf
of new hampshire association of criminal
defense lawyers
innovation in our court system is
critical as a service provider that does
essential work courts must keep running
regardless of circumstances to do this
they must embrace change
but as with all forms of government in
the end those changes must work and if
you heard from uh attorney hawks those
changes aren't working and i don't have
the data that he does because he runs
the essentially the largest law firm in
the state but my anecdotal experience as
a trial lawyer and a criminal defense
lawyer for 18 years confirms what he
told you
felonies first was a huge change and
after at least five years of experience
it's safe to say that it doesn't work
for the people that are served by the
court
there are three reasons or three points
i want to make about this first it
represents an increased workload county
attorney's offices were directly
impacted by felonies first
and in my professional life as a lawyer
and in my personal life as friends with
other lawyers i can tell you that this
increased workload has been difficult
their prosecutor's job is hard
and turnover is normal but the rate of
turnover at the county attorney's
offices since felonies versus
implemented has skyrocketed
this has resulted in many more attorneys
per case than before prior to felonies
first in my experience it was uncommon
to have more than two different
attorneys on a case now in the county
where i practice most hillsborough
county two attorneys is about average
and on some older cases it's up to four
or five i had a trial this november this
past november and there have been six
attorneys on the case
turnover is bad for the state it's bad
for the defendant it's bad for the
victims and it's bad for court it eats
up all of the promised time savings that
originally motivated felonies first
on a personal note i've had many friends
who were great attorneys go into and
then leave the county attorney's office
in fact my law partner is only in my law
the increased workload that felonies
first represents is great
the next thing that i want to bring to
the the committee's attention is that it
has been less speedy and more expensive
uh the chair estimated that the number
was 11
of felonies that resolved in district
court in my 12 years as a public
defender and my six years in private
practice obviously the last six years
didn't have anything to do with felonies
first my experience was that the number
was closer to the 37 percent that
attorney hawks gave you a vast vast vast
plurality of cases especially the
low-level felonies were dealt with in
district court
because felonies first makes that
impossible
the cost to the defendant and the pace
of the case is slowed down for example
if you look just at the rules the rules
in district court have one or two
hearings mandatory and the rules in
superior court have many more than that
approximately three times the number of
hearings
as a result this makes the process
slower and it makes it more expensive
and all of this is true prior to the
covid caused backlog
the important thing to look at when
you're considering this bill
is not the time that it took to resolve
felonies before felonies first and now
but the time it took to resolve all
felonies including those that were
resolved as misdemeanors in the district
court
this goes to a point i wanted to make
when you're talking about blame i don't
think that it's fair to say that any one
party is to blame the county attorneys
the defense lawyers the courts the
problem was with felonies first is the
premise
the premise was that we could resolve
all of these low-level felonies with
these high-level felonies and do it
equally quickly they basically scooped
up the bottom and they put it with the
top but my experience as a trial lawyer
and i think all the trial lawyers that
are going to testify after me would
agree
that the vast majority of the time and
energy spent in superior court is
dedicated to a very small number of
cases domestic violence cases involving
serious injury
or homicide
or sexual assault cases and lumping
those very complex victim-centered cases
in with cases like low-level possession
charges makes no sense that was the
fundamental error in thinking behind
felonies first the low-level possessions
are much more like
the misdemeanor cases that the district
court deals with than the felony cases
that take up 90 of the time in superior
court
and this brings me to my last point
i
love
being a lawyer
i
love
our court systems when i go on vacation
i make a point to find out what the
local court looks like if there is a
lawyer equivalent of a gym rat that is
me i will go and watch other people
argue i will go and watch other judges
rule on cases because i enjoy the legal
process
but the key thing
about the legal process especially in a
state like new hampshire is the
personnel the people that are involved
that make decisions the rules are
important but the people matter more and
that's why i think felonies first is not
good for everyone it takes away an
element of local control
and i want to give you a quick example
when i was a public defender i went out
to the milford district court and there
was a notorious
chicken thief
that was regularly punished in the
milford district court this gentleman
was a homeless individual he had pretty
serious mental illness and so on hot
days when there were barbecues he would
walk through the backyards of people's
neighbors neighborhoods and he would
take chicken off their grill he would
never take all their chicken
that guy got in trouble a bunch and so
the third strike theft law kicked in
but the local police officers who knew
this guy who understood who he was and
why he did what he did and the judge in
that case she had seen him as a juvenile
and she had been his judge for 20 years
she knew when he was having problems she
knew when it was serious and when it was
just somebody being poor and the
punishments that the prosecutors offered
and that the judges crafted for this
gentleman were different in a way that
only local control can allow now when
that case goes up to the superior court
what you get is a series of emails
between the prosecutor and the police
department you lose the texture you lose
the individuality you lose the
personality and the personal knowledge
of people in a way that can't be
replicated so think about this if i am a
drug dealer and i am in downtown
manchester and i finish dealing all but
like a little bit of my drugs and i get
picked up they're going to look at the
drug and they're going to look at the
weight and they're going to craft a
charge based on those two things
if i am a drug addict and i have
finished most of what i need to
supplement my
you know mental illness and my addiction
and i get picked up with the exact same
drug and the exact same amount
the police on the streets are the people
who will know which person is the drug
dealer and which person is the drug
addict and they will know that before
the defense lawyer before the judge and
before the county attorney
those people should have input and
crafting decisions and i think that when
we had
felonies start out in district court
that sort of information was carried
into the case it was brought into the
courtroom and it fashioned better faster
and just
more just results
i want to take and answer a couple of
questions so there was a question about
reverting back
i think that because of
the way in which this
bill is is written and interacts with
the uh the e-filing provisions it would
not be exactly the same so
passing this law would not essentially
turn out turn back the clock because the
e-filing rules that govern superior
court make it a little different
there was a question about the pc
requirement the case is gerstein versus
pew and i i know judge gordon knows this
i just want to tell the court while
there is no hard and fast requirement
that you have to have a probable cause
hearing if time looks like it's going to
be so great then you can get a probable
cause hearing and that's what happened
in gerstein versus q it was a kentucky
case and the guy got held for what ended
up being three years pre-trial so there
is no explicit you must have a pc
hearing but when timetables get long you
should get one and that's what the
constitution says
in terms of the circuit court overload
which i thought was a very real concern
in my experience
my anecdotal experience matches the
numbers that attorney hawks gave you the
vast majority of pc hearings were waived
and as judge gordon pointed out people
act when they have deadlines and i am a
firm believer that if you get two
lawyers on a case together
even if you just get them together on a
street corner they're going to make
progress on the case and by having a pc
hearing even if you don't have it you
make progress on the case so having a
revert back to district court to do pc
hearings is not going to represent a
substantial burden the other thing that
i want to point out is that our
circuit court judges are incredibly deft
at handling caseloads and so what they
traditionally did in my experience when
they had pc hearings is they would take
the pc hearing at the beginning of the
session
do the pc hearing and then everybody
else would go out and negotiate their
case while the pc hearing was coming or
was going on and then when the pc
hearing ended all of those cases would
come in and they would have resolutions
ready instead of waiting for lawyers to
go resolve the case or wait for their
case to get called they use that time
really well and i think you know a
couple of judges that did it really well
the current judge that sits and she sits
all over the place but judge chabot who
used to be a prosecutor in the hooksett
district court she does this even though
they don't have pc hearings with other
hearings that are going to take more
time and so if you go to the district
court you will see how skilled these
people are at spinning 16 plates at once
and i don't think that it would add a
substantial burden to them the other
thing is in talking to prosecutors it
would offer some sort of savings because
filing cases
using the felonies first system
especially for police prosecutors
represents work so it would essentially
take a little bit of that work away and
may add a little bit
in terms of probable cause hearings but
the vast vast majority of probable cause
hearings were waived and like i said i i
was a court rat and i loved having
hearings and so it was also a way to
build rapport with my client so i had
more than the average lawyer but even i
was waving something like 90 or 95
percent of pc
hearings so
if there are no other questions uh i'm i
would ask for permission to be excused
thank you very much
yes you know
i guess we we have a question here i'm
sorry
thank you for taking my question you
know i'm looking at this and i don't
know a heck of a lot about the criminal
process in courts but
is it possible to
try lower level
felonies in circuit court and then the
higher level felonies the really serious
ones in superior court so that's an
excellent question and that's something
that uh people have talked about for a
while if you go to our neighbor state to
the south
and you only go there you know because
they might have more restaurants
but uh they have a system that has a
three-tier approach they have a system
that involves
that involves misdemeanors concurrent
felonies and felonies and so in
massachusetts you can get a jury trial
on a concurrent felony in some
circumstances in what would be and it's
not a direct equivalent but in what
would be similar to our circuit court so
that that is something that has tried
and it does seem to work again the real
flaw with felonies first and your
question points this out is that you're
taking
cases that are not like each other and
you're clumping them together for
thank you
okay uh if there's no other questions
thank you for your testimony this
morning
the chair will not recognize richard
head
[Music]
morning mr chair members of the
committee my name is richard head i'm
the government affairs coordinator for
the judicial branch
i did want to read something to you very
briefly this is the
[Music]
fiscal impact statement that was offered
to
the judicial branch at the time felonies
first was proposed
and we wrote back in 2015 this bill will
eliminate the duplicative initiation of
a felony case in the district division
of the circuit court
currently a felony begins by filing a
charge in district division of the
circuit court where an arraignment by
the way 85 percent or so of arraignments
were waived
an arraignment but it was scheduled
100 of the time 85 percent of the time
was waived
whether an arraignment a bail hearing
and a probable cause hearing are
scheduled the case is then transferred
called bound over in the statutory
language through the superior court
anywhere from 90 to 120 days after the
case has been transferred is then
presented to the grand jury for
indictment which constitutes a second
filing a probable cause and the process
begins again in the superior court with
an arraignment and a bail hearing
the staffs in both courts spend a
significant amount of time transferring
the case from the district division of
circuit court to the superior court and
matching the transferred file to the
subsequent indictments that come
in the superior court
in the staff time that would be saved
from uh this new process felonies first
was was the reference point
in general and i'm going to give you
some more statistics and data and i
apologize for that a little bit but i
think it is useful and it is useful to
go back to what we are talking about in
2015 with that multiple stage process
in that multiple stage process each of
those has time each of those has
elements of confusion and each of those
has elements of mistakes get built into
the system and i want to talk briefly
about each of those
so
in 2015
the time it would take in the circuit
court to bound over and i'm talking
averages and i'm talking average times
to disposition
it was about 58 days let's round it up
to 60 days
so in circuit court by the time it was
filed to the time of bound over on
average was about two months and that
gets you through the arraignment and the
other procedural elements that are
occurring in circuit court
it is then bound over where the file is
held nothing can happen on that file
once it's bound over into the superior
court until an indictment is filed and
that indictment then
tees up and triggers the the superior
court action
and
by rule that has to happen within about
90 days sometimes it's less sometimes
the 90 days is waived and it's more
but in general we'll call it 90 days
so we have the 60 days about in superior
in in circuit court 90 days in uh in
essentially limbo waiting for an
indictment so we haven't even started in
superior court under the old system
and then we get to a superior court and
it was about 175 days at that point
and that's the average of time of
disposition in superior court
add those three components up you start
in superior in circuit court you bound
over you wait for an indictment you then
start up again in superior court
that was about 323 days
average time to disposition
we then fast forward to 2019 and as
you've heard we have the the 2020 time
frame becomes complicated with the
pandemic
but let's take 2019 by then
essentially the shift had been completed
in felonies first
so if you remember the three steps in in
pre-felonies first circuit court bound
over
sort of uh waiting for indictment and
then superior court cases was 323 days
in superior court the average timed
disposition is 194 days so that total
and again talking averages 323 roughly
to
194. if you look at 2020 just to put the
pandemic into perspective that 194 bumps
up to 234.
so quartz were operating courts are
functional during the pandemic
everything slows down a little bit so
it's a little bit everything becomes a
little bit harder
so let's talk about what that means in
terms of
impact on people
so let's talk about the victims of crime
victims of crime are under the old
system
they have a case that is in circuit
court
so so there's a there's a in in county
attorney offices you have victim
advocates the attorney general's office
has a victim advocate
you have a
a
less
complete system of victim assistance at
the local level some are very good at it
some just don't have the capacity to
provide victim assistance when you're
talking local prosecutors local local
departments and again some are very good
some just don't have the resources so a
victim service is a much different
image at the circuit court level than it
is at the superior court level when the
county's attorney's offices are involved
the county attorney victim advocates
become involved
and
and the victims of crime have a point of
contact
even those where you have a more
sophisticated
locality where in the circuit court you
have a victim assistance program
there's a change in everything changes
from circuit court to superior court it
is
a very confusing time
for a victim of crime trying to figure
out
why am i now in a different court why do
i have different prosecutors why is why
do i not have sort of a person that's
the same point of contact it creates an
element of confusion
we also look at it from the perspective
of within the administrative office of
courts the domestic violence registry so
if there is a crime that triggers
a crime of domestic violence that
triggers a a requirement of reporting
to the federal system to the gun line to
to
within the various notices
when that when that
initial case is filed and let's say
there's a restraining order put into
effect or a
bail order
that is put into effect that requires a
report that's reported to our system
every time there's a change in the data
whether it be a case number whether it
be a court whether whatever it may be
every time there's a change the domestic
violence register a registry has to
update the records
every
it is human nature that mistakes happen
uh so
the more steps you add the more changes
you add the greater the level of
complication the greater the risk of
mistakes
file in one place you have fewer
mistakes you have the same case number
you have the same uh
activity so another example on that
another change that can happen is in
circuit court
you can have bail conditions that are
applied
that can then that gets bound over to
superior court superior court is now
waiting gets the indictment
there can be new and different
conditions placed by the superior court
judge because we now have a new new case
new look
those all have to get
added within the domestic violence
registry so again more updates more more
complications
one of the questions that that was
mentioned earlier was well you know what
happened in circuit court once these
cases were were no longer part of
felonies first they all went to to
circuit court and you've heard some
suggestion of it is a remarkably busy
place
you have
a group of judges that are dealing with
on average about
125 000 cases a year
it is a huge volume of cases that that
are in
circuit court and they deal with
domestic violence there are civil cases
there are criminal cases there are
guardianship cases adoptions involuntary
admissions
it is a a remarkable place where
i i'm going to get this wrong i think
that there are 47 judges
in the circuit court dealing with 125
000 cases in dealing with
with deadlines and cases that have to be
dealt with on an expedited basis
in 2015
there were roughly
672 cases that were filed as felonies
that's what we're talking about in terms
of the pool in 2015 of what would be
felony first cases
so what is being proposed is a shift of
let's add and again i'm not the the
number today might be different than the
number in 2015 but let's say they were
equal we're adding 6 000 more cases to
the circuit court system
and then there was a question about bail
reform and there's some there's some
legislation about bail reform um and
you know last year it was senate bill 92
this year senator bradley has a has a
bill
that would require um
that would prevent a bail from uh from
being done through a bail commissioner
that would have to be held and you have
to have a bail hearing in circuit court
that's another so if something like that
passes we're talking another 3 000 cases
in in circuit court that are not
currently pending every time there's
sort of a change and there's an addition
to
cases in the circuit court you're adding
to what is already a stressed system and
you're adding to an already stressed
system today in a period of covid
a system that is stressed a little
bumped up because of covet
you have staff shortages
similar to everybody else i'm not going
to say that the issues that you heard
and that you will hear are not real
obviously we've heard of of amazing and
just tremendous stresses in the public
defender's office you hear that in the
in the in the county attorneys all of
those are real and they're also real in
the in the circuit court
things to to also think about is you
know some of the data about
you know felonies the percentage of
felonies that were resolved
pre-felonies first and post-felonies
first and that comes down
you also then have to look at similar
question that was raised before
was felonies first the cause of that
because the other aspect of of what
felonies first does is
it brings in a more sophisticated i'll
use that term loosely
charging process where the county
attorneys are involved at the beginning
and it very well could be and probably
is
that cases that were being charged as
felonies are getting a slightly more
thorough look and they're being charged
as misdemeanors there's nothing that
prohibits a charge from going as a
misdemeanor if that case is truly a
misdemeanor
and the other aspect and the other thing
to keep in mind is
a a case filed as a felony in the
circuit court cannot get resolved as a
felony in the circuit court
if that is going to be settled as a
felony it's going to superior court you
have to
misdemeanors are the ones that get
resolved
in circuit court so if it's being pled
down to a misdemeanor it can get
resolved in circuit court but if it's
being pled as a misdemeanor you're going
over to superior court in superior court
you can
resolve a case as either a felony or a
misdemeanor sometimes those cases are
null processed and sent back to circuit
court which creates a whole different
sort of process problem
but in superior court you can and and
frequently do seek cases that were filed
as felonies resolving as as misdemeanors
one of the other questions that was
raised are
is essentially are we going back and
reverting to identical situations uh
pre-felonies first 2015
one of the significant changes that has
occurred and there was a reference to it
is e-filing so electronic filing is is
what's happening in superior court is
not the same in circuit court the old
days bound over was the clerk in circuit
court took that file and brought it over
to superior court it was sort of a
physical process not actually sure how
today we would figure it out
and and and
and just to be clear we're not taking a
position on the policy of this bill we
do and are providing information and
testimony as to sort of the impacts
because those impacts
um uh correlate to sort of your
decision-making process
but the
the um
the addition of electronic filing sort
of creates this level of of complexity
that did not exist
pre-2015 when felonies first went into
effect
because ultimately
the
um
you know how that file who is going to
electronically file and how it's going
to get electronically filed will have to
figure out but there just may be there
are complications associated with that i
guess is the is the easiest way to to
and the last thing i'll
note is
you know there are opportunities to
resolve in superior court
early case resolution if there if there
needs to be some changes to that great
that doesn't mean you you take away
felonies first it doesn't mean you sort
of revert back to 2015 it means okay
let's look at the process and if there
are tweaks that need to be done we can
we can manage that but those
opportunities do exist and they are real
and i get everybody's incredibly busy
and i get it's hard to sort of think
about a case that's not in front of you
because you don't have a deadline today
but the you know there is early case
resolution as you heard earlier there
there are actually more
sort of hearings that occur in superior
court you can always get to resolution
at any of those
um and and cases are resolving
and i think on an overall basis they are
resolving in terms of if you look at
time of disposition
in a shorter period of time
on average some are longer some are
shorter
and you avoid
the three-step
process of
filing in circuit court having your
hearings in circuit court
then saying okay this is still a felony
we're going to bound it over we're going
to bind it over to
spirit court it's going to hang in
superior court for a little while
until we get an indictment and then
we're going to resolve it
and that that sort of multi-step
process which creates confusion
opportunity for errors
um is is gone
um
and
and with that i'd be happy to
uh
to take any questions thank you
any questions for mr head yes
representative chase thank you very much
mr chair and thank you attorney head for
taking
my question i'm i'm a little confused
you said um
that you're not really
taking a position on this yet it sounded
to me very opposed i also wanted to know
not that you could do what you want i'm
just that's the way it came across to me
with all the statistics that you're
talking about
and wouldn't
this using the electronic filing
actually simplify things and take out
some of those steps
where the high-level felonies would not
be significant
and the cases could be resolved
without going through all of the the
process and the steps that you told
about the 60 days 90 days in the 175.
so thank you for the question um
relative to the first one we don't you
know there are policy issues relative to
whether or not we we go stick with
felonies first or not
that policy thing is what i'm saying we
are not taking a position on i do and
the purpose of my testimony is there is
a significant negative impact on the
circuit court if this were to pass
and that's i think important for you to
know as legislators because ultimately
that policy decision you're going to
make is going to have if you choose to
to go with this bill is going to have a
significant
potential impact on the circuit court
system so i think it is important for
you to understand to know
the current stresses that exist in the
circuit court system
and
in in sort of how
the reversion back to the old system
essentially creates this this thing that
that we were trying to fix back in 2015.
so so while i don't have a position on
the policy per se i do have a
you know i do think it's important and i
do and i agree with you there's my
information has been negative in the
sense of of the
of this bill because this bill has a
negative impact but ultimately that is a
fair to say it's a legislative decision
on whether you know the policy is it
outweighs that negative impact
as your other question i may i'm not
sure i fully understood it but the
e-filing is simply the way in which the
the case is put into the the superior
court system
the the difficulty becomes one circuit
court
would have
it's not clear who's actually going to
e-file what is in
circuit court because we're not a party
but the circuit court would either
e-file it somehow into the superior
court or the superior court would take
the paper file
scan it but they don't have a file
number yet their files don't open until
the indictment
so the the superior court process begins
with the indictment
so they have a file with no home until
there's an indictment
so it just creates some logistical
questions as to sort of what do you do
with it
um and and yes we would figure it out
but it's not
it's not
simple
um and and we would also have to then
sort of work with the e-filing system
and the vendor for that as to exactly
how that all works
and their expenses associated with that
we did have a fiscal note
it's indeterminable
because it is always it's hard to know
we have
you know our our our estimate is that
the
impact will be greatest in the four
busiest circuit courts
um so you're you're essentially talking
manchester uh concord keene
nashua
area but doesn't mean they're not
impacts everywhere but we highlighted
those as as
where we would have the greatest fiscal
impact and
both in terms of of judicial resources
and
clerk staff resources you know the just
the volume of of material that comes
through circuit court is astronomical uh
and and just the management of files
uh is is difficult the scheduling
getting you know these hearings
scheduled the other the other aspect of
of sort of the the
um
the initial arrangements is or i'm sorry
probable cause hearings is they are
100 scheduled 85 waived
um
in that process though you still have to
frequently waived on the day of
or or thereabouts um so you have
uh
local prosecutors assuming because they
have to assume there's a hearing even
though it's not going forward you have
victims who are assuming there's going
to be hearing that doesn't go forward um
you it it creates confusion um
in the in the system in spirit court you
don't have that required
you're going to have it you have to ask
for it
system and it it does
have a an inherent benefit and
efficiency
in the sense of
not having to assume
until it's until it's taken off that
any further questions
cnn thank you very much thank you thank
you for letting me testify
good morning
my name is jim moyer and
i want to speak in favor of the bill
i live in canterbury
i work out of concord i've been a
criminal defense lawyer for
approximately 38 years
first 10 years i was a public defender
new hampshire public defender program
after that as in private practice but
also did contract work
and i feel i'm very familiar with the
system
back when the felony's first
legislation was contemplated back in
i must admit i was skeptical of it
for a variety of reasons and indeed
virtually every practitioner both
prosecutor and defense attorney i knew
at that time was skeptical as well
and i think my skepticism has been borne
out by many of the statistics you've
heard already
i i want to tell you though i'm speaking
strictly anecdotally from my own
experience in the system i don't have
the figures and facts others have been
providing those to you but i but i i i
think what i've experienced is reflected
in those numbers
the issue really is the cultures between
and judge gordon talked about this the
culture is very different between the
circuit court and the superior court
as you've heard many times your circuit
court is very active lots of cases going
through i would say that circuit courts
are are very nimble
they use their time efficiently they
move things along and everybody sort of
agrees let's get the cases going
whichever case it is whether it's small
claims or criminal violation i mean
indeed they deal with speeding tickets
you know the most minor stuff but they
do it efficiently superior court
generally has dealt with more serious
cases and it's more deliberative it's
more ponderous i'd say it definitely
moves moves more slowly
this is why when i when i when judge
gordon talked about this and attorney
hawks as well
having the felonies start in the
district court
because you have the preliminary and the
probable cause you're scheduled
everyone has a deadline to look at
and
many of these cases in my experience
personally it's been at least 50 percent
of the felonies were resolved in the
district report level um that's a huge
amount and it's done very quickly and
very efficiently and that's really what
i want to stress here
um the way it worked and the way we had
it going for
i have no idea certainly as long as i
practice probably a hundred years doing
it the way we did prior to felonies
first it worked and i really felt at the
time that felonies first was a solution
looking for a problem
it was it was working there was no
reason to change it everything can
always be tweaked but again it was an
experiment that didn't work
um so basically i wanted to say that i'm
in favor of this legislation i thought
the way it worked before was great
worked well let's go back to it
any questions for attorney moyer
seeing none thank you very much thank
you
good morning
i'm paul halverson i'm the merrimack
county attorney
by way of background i've been
practicing only criminal law since 2000.
i was a public defender before moving to
being a prosecutor i practice in circuit
court and superior courts in four
different counties
mr hawks attorney hawks and attorney
scotland briny
gave you some of their observations and
numbers i'm not going to repeat them i
was going to use some of their numbers
in my in my presentation attorney hawks
and i spoke a little bit monday
for probably a half hour 40 minutes
about those specific statistics uh and i
have no issue with his uh with his
numbers they parallel some of the
numbers that uh that i was able to uh
turn out from my
um case management software
what we've done
with felonies first
in my opinion is create an artificial
choke point
at the superior courts
you've heard the term many hands make
easy work
what we've done we've taken all the
felony cases that origin used to
originate in the circuit courts
and move them up to the superior courts
in the first instance
that has forced everything through that
funnel of superior court
you've heard about some of the
resolution numbers
um from mr hawks mr mr skull and briny
touched on them uh briefly uh and and
i'm concerned with
the
length of time cases are open and the
decrease in resolution uh numbers uh
from
2000 early teens data
from the court system
they had commented that the number of
felonies percent of felonies resolved in
in district courts
belknap was 21
carroll was 19 cheshire county was 20
percent cost county 27 grafton county 17
merrimack county 16 hillsborough county
14 percent
rockingham 22 percent stratfor county 26
and sullivan county 19
that comes from the court's own data
from the early part of the 2000s
since the beginning of
felonies first anecdotally i believe
that that again there was artificial
choke point up at the superior courts
when i became county attorney a little
more than a year ago i started looking
at at the number of hearings we've been
having
just in final number of charges filed
for felonies i ran these numbers
recently
in 2016 we filed 981 felonies that's
pretty much pre-felony's first righteous
felonies first was beginning to roll out
in 2021 we filed 1235 felony cases
felonies only
now remember each of those felonies
from felonies first may have an
attendant misdemeanor so the case
numbers are are dramatically higher but
i'm talking just felonies so between 19
2016 and 2021
we've increased about 254 charges about
26 percent
that's a dramatic increase and the only
increa the only difference is felonies
first um anecdotally i do not believe
the crime rate has gone up for felonies
by 25 in merrimack county during that
same time period
we looked at court dates
uh time in court between 2016 i should
say we i should say aye
between 2016 and 2021
i looked at two events arraignments and
bail
arraignment days
one arraignment one day in court in 2016
was 776
an arraignment event counting as an
arraignment day in 2021
went up to 923. that's an increase or
just shy of 20 of 20
um and again the only common factor for
those numbers is felonies first when we
look at bail hearings
this is the dramatic increase for bail
hearings we went from 254 court days
in 2016
to 452 court days in 2021. that's an
increase of just under 78 percent and
that's just in merrimack county court
the ripple effect with the other courts
i'm willing to bet uh if not close at
least parallel those individual numbers
mr hawkes presented the data
regarding the weeks to resolve felony
cases
between 2015 and 2020
he was reluctant to comment about the in
the number of weeks to resolve the case
in 20 and 21 obviously for coveted
reasons
but i was talking to a couple of the
attorneys in the office the other day
regarding some of these numbers that mr
hawkes had provided me on monday and
presented to you earlier today
and
one of the attorneys commented that even
during the onset of the pandemic
the circuit courts were doing many many
telephonic hearings
and they were resolving cases
telephonically with submitted paperwork
from public defenders and retained
counsel
what that means is had a felony
originated in my observation had a
felony originated in a circuit court
and they were able to resolve a
misdemeanor resolution
for the less serious offenses
those cases could have been resolved
earlier
but they were not because of some of the
court processes that were involved with
the with the superior court so that was
another impact of
of felonies first
i i found interesting mr hawk's number
of
uh the number of district court
resolutions
um
in the uh regarding felonies in 2015. he
mentioned the numbers um 37 percent
resolved in merrimack county 18 weeks
quicker than after felonies first
that tells me
that
that felonies first was again the only
common denominator
in that in his analysis for all of his
statistical numbers was felonies first
that just reinforces the choke point
uh point that i'm that i'm bringing out
regarding everything now originating up
in superior courts
i listened with with interest to some of
the prior testimony i made some notes
that
that i want to comment on one is
gatekeeping
it was mentioned that the county
attorneys are are
involved sooner with felonies first
well that may have been the hope
but i can tell you that the gatekeeper
now for a felony charge is the police
department and the bail commissioner
and i say that because a police officer
will arrest for whatever charges are
applicable
and then he has probable cause for
uh when he makes the when he affects the
arrest
if it's a felony and a bail commissioner
bails that person to appear in superior
court
that's what starts the superior court
docket
and i can tell you that that because of
the choke point
in superior court
the superior court in my in my
observations is having a difficult
difficult time keeping up with some of
the administrative process
i'll give you a recent example
there was individual arrested earlier in
january earlier this month
he has an arraignment scheduled
for today
as of yesterday the court didn't have a
daca number for him
that means that my office is unable to
file
any charge
in superior court because we cannot
electronically file it without a docket
number
now do i know where that paperwork is i
don't
but
we have to ask ourselves a bigger
question as society is that defendant
getting getting justice if i can't file
a complaint
in a speedy manner because process is
not being uh because the the paperwork
is not being processed to open it at a
superior court is that is is that a good
thing
i think not
that's just a recent observation
another recent observation regarding
electronic issues
the backlog and workload and my
observations at superior court
are are so high we're having difficulty
getting
final orders out after a resolution
i'll tell you a recent impact for that
we had we had a final order come to us
almost four months after sentencing
that individual was ordered to be on
probation
probation never knew he was on probation
we never knew
that the uh we never received the final
order so without a final order there is
no final order
we could not talk to the probation guys
we can tell them you can expect them
waiting on a final order
that individual never reported to a
probation
four months four-month period
that because of a backlog at the courts
and getting orders out
that that individual went that's i don't
say missing but i'll say without
resolution
now again as society i don't think
that's a good thing
i think he i think as a defendant he's
expecting that to be
his case to be resolved and updated he
resolves it in court
i think the defense attorney is
expecting to get an order in a timely
manner
i think the uh the the state i'm
certainly expecting to get to get an
order in a timely manner and the impact
there was obviously a person wasn't
being supervised who a judge thought
ought to be supervised when from the
bench he
indicated he was going to order a period
of probation
that
there was some talk about
other counties
and i know a wmur report
between judge
showed a conversation between judge
coughlin and judge delker down in
hillsborough county
and that conversation had to do with um
uh basically
doing triage for lack of a better term
with cases prior to coming to superior
court they were talking
generally about the backlogs and
difficulties and and
staffing and i couldn't agree with it
with the comments more um
that the circuit court is definitely a
triage court for low for lower hang
felony issues
and with this change in legislation
in my opinion it puts us back where we
were
prior to felonies first
now i can tell you that that the court
administrative rules the court rules
it won't be difficult in my estimation
for the court rules to be reinstated
and
they they had the historical documents
for those court rules
so those should be not heavy lifting for
the courts and plus the the lead in time
is great enough that i think that
they'll be able to to accommodate that
um
attorney head talked about 58 days to
bind overs
out of the out of the circuit courts
one thing to realize in the circuit
courts again having done
probably hundreds of probable cause
hearings and dealt with attorneys on
many many many felony cases
it's not uncommon
for a local prosecutor to coordinate
with the
county attorney's office and count in
resolutions of those uh uh
more appropriate for resolution cases in
in circuit court
routinely as a lower level prosecutor
i'd pick up the phone and call the
county attorney's office and say hey
attorney jones
i have mr smith this is the facts of
case are you okay with me resolving it
we banter it back back and forth we talk
about possible resolutions they'd give
me the okay i'd start negotiations with
defense counsel off times a probable
cause hearing may be moved one or two
times but ultimately resolve in the in
the lower court
it was
more common
um than uh than most people would would
think and again the numbers that tony
hawks presented earlier
beared that out
bears that out
i believe
mr gordon representative gordon
mentioned
and several people that testified
mentioned earlier intervention
i don't think i can emphasize that
enough
the local courts really have a good feel
on
uh individuals that are before the court
on a regular basis they really do
the local judge sees them on a regular
basis local prosecutor sees them on a
regular basis they have a feel for
what's needed for a decent resolution a
just resolution an appropriate
resolution for the individual
and with the programs that are available
in the lower courts they can institute
that much quicker than they can at the
and that includes mental health
i guess
the bottom line is
on a policy basis
where the work needs to be performed and
the costs associated with it you have to
weigh that against
what amounts to and i'll be blunt about
this what amounts to the liberty
interests of of a defendant
now
to be quite blunt about it i take the
liberty entrance of the people that i
prosecute that our office prosecutes
very seriously
um and so does everybody in my office i
drive that point uh
home hard with the 17 attorneys that
work in my office
and uh and and i think
that if there's a cost
to ensure the liberty interests of
defendants
are protected we should absorb it end of
the end of discussion
felonies first as it was as it was
anticipated
hoped to assist in that
uh to to meet that goal it didn't work
it's not working
so i support the bill
um and i gladly answer any questions
that anyone may uh may have
do we have any questions from the
committee oh we do representative chase
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question it's
more of a um
kind of a concern you used a example of
a person who was sentenced and no final
order was sent down
to the probation so he was just out or
he she the person was out unsupervised
am i incorrect that when someone is
sentenced that aren't they usually taken
back to a holding cell or somewhere
until then his sentence didn't involve a
uh a a stan committed sentence so he
basically walked out of courtroom on
that day
so
with the final order uh he would have
been ordered to report to probation but
that final order again was delayed so
one follow-up just i just want to
understand all of this thank you very
much so where did the ball kind of drop
was it because of the backload that the
paperwork didn't get done and just how
often does this happen specifically
i i can't say where the ball dropped
between the courtroom
uh colloquy with the judge and and the
plea being entered and approved to and
us getting the electronic order of the
court i don't know if
where within the courthouse it fell
but we didn't receive it for four months
and um all of our court documents are
dated when they're transmitted to us
electronically at the bottom of the dock
of the document
and
the
order
uh is dated on the date at the end of
his plea but the transmission date to us
was that three and a half four months
later
we all set any further questions
cnn thank you very much for your
testimony thank you
the chair now recognizes andrew
laverne hey five pronouns
i was very close not quite okay thank
good morning mr chairman members of the
committee my name is andrew livernoise i
am the belknap county attorney
and i am here to testify despite my
friendship with attorney halverson
let me begin by saying that i recognize
that felonies first which was
established in 2016 is not perfect
it has failed in
several ways to provide all the benefits
that it was promised it has
significantly increased caseloads for
county attorneys offices there is no
doubt about that uh it has increased the
caseload of my office tremendously
i've been lucky in that my delegation
has supported my office despite these
changes we saw it coming my predecessor
saw it coming back in 2015.
we added extra staff to our uh we added
an extra assistant county attorney in
2016 in anticipation of the increased
caseload this year the delegation is
providing me with another assistant
county attorney so i won't pretend that
it has not had attendant costs on the
county
but having said that i think it would be
a serious mistake to dismantle the
felony's first program
and to go back to the way cases were
handled previously
and my reason for saying that uh has to
do with
well let me say i think it is
felonies first has
improved our ability to prosecute felony
cases effectively and efficiently and to
provide justice in a way that is
supportive to victims
in my office we have now adjusted to
this new system we're used to this new
system i have office protocols and
policies in place to deal with the new
pro this new system and to try to
dismantle it and go back to the old way
of doing business i think would be a
mistake and to see why
my focus is on the serious cases and
that's where i think felonies first is
really most important
because i think you have to think about
what happens in a smaller rural
community when a serious crime occurs
let's say it is a serious domestic
violence case involving a bodily injury
a sexual assault case or a non-fatal
shooting case
under the current system under felonies
first
if the when the police make an arrest in
that case and the defendant is held
overnight my office
knows about that case at eight o'clock
the next morning
my office can immediately get involved
in the case
we are reaching out to the police
department to get relevant documents
we're reviewing those documents we're
working with the police department to
help get additional evidence to maybe
help them decide about
getting search warrants things like that
and then either i or one of my assistant
county attorneys who i've hired
trained supervised is going to make the
decision about what crimes to charge in
that case
and we're going to draft those charging
documents and we're going to file those
documents electronically and we're going
to be involved right from the beginning
and under felonies first the same lawyer
will handle that case from beginning to
end
and i think that's important that
principle is known as vertical
prosecution where one prosecutor handles
the case from the beginning all the way
to the end it's considered i think best
practices around the country
and most uh i think many prosecution
agencies around the country use a
vertical integration system
what else happens right away that first
that first morning however
in my office i have two full-time victim
witness advocates and on a serious case
involving victims that first morning my
victim witness advocates are reaching
out to those victims to give them
services to make sure they understand
the court process to see if they want to
be involved in the bail decision to see
if they want to be involved in the bail
hearing that's going to take place that
day
in my county
the
local police departments don't have
victim with victim witness advocates
and so
i think it's important that my office be
involved immediately and that my victim
would his advocates be involved
immediately
if felonies first were dismantled we
went back to the old way of doing things
it means those preliminary parts of the
case
the charging decisions
the bail hearing the probable cause
hearing the notifications to victims
would most likely revert back to
the police prosecutors who handled those
cases previously those police
prosecutors who are hired by and
employed by the police departments
now i don't
want in any way to disparage the work of
the local police prosecutors in my
county i work closely with all of them i
respect all of them they do terrific and
outstanding work but ultimately i'm
responsible for the all criminal
prosecutions in my county and i don't
have
day-to-day supervision over the local
police prosecutors
and on a serious felony charge involving
a victim i want my attorneys to be
now alternatively
it might be argued that i could simply
assign my staff
to do those preliminary parts on the
serious felonies in the lower district
courts but that means now i have to be
sending my
attorneys to multiple district courts
throughout the county we have a district
court over in franklin we have a
district court in laconia it means my
prosecutors now have to be juggling
different court procedures in different
courtrooms
i would prefer to have it all take place
in the superior court in my
in the same building where we work
now
uh there's been a lot of talk about the
fact that because felonies first
has moved all the cases to superior
court the sort of low-hanging fruit
of the low-level drug cases and things
like that aren't being resolved uh as
quickly and i understand that has been a
concern but what we are doing in my
county is my prosecutors were working to
try to be more nimble like the
prosecutors in district court were
we are trying to resolve cases as early
as we can we are trying to negotiate
early with uh with defense counsel move
cases back to district court when they
really should be misdemeanors plead
cases out as misdemeanors early
for felonies first to work you have to
have an effective ecr program and i
think if there's any flaw in felonies
first that's the biggest flaw is that
the ecr program has not always been as
robust as it should be and if we were
going to try to change something my
recommendation would be to improve the
ecr program
rather than eliminate felonies first
additionally if you were to dismantle
felonies first i think there are
additional
uh
drawbacks or
costs resulting just from the change
over itself
at this point all of the police
departments in my county are used to
felonies first they've been trained on
how to do felonies first what paperwork
needs to be filed where it needs to be
filed by what time it needs to be sent
in we've created case management
programs to effectively handle the flow
of felony cases from beginning to end
all of that would have to be altered if
you were to undo felonies first
none of my attorneys have ever worked
under the old system so all of my
attorneys
would basically be learning this new
system
which is now going to the old system
so rather than
undoing the felony's first program i
would recommend that this
that instead we undertake a systematic
examination of the sorts of changes we
can make to make this program work
better
and be more effective
and with that i would uh oh i should
also point out that
as the association of counties has
the majority of the county attorneys in
this state
would prefer not to see felonies first
dismantled
representative lorenzo thank you mr
claire um would you
do you have handouts for us
i have um
i apologize i didn't print out handouts
for you i submitted written testimony
which is largely mirrored with what i
just said which i put on the portal
uh you have a
so it's on the portal
um if you would like i could uh after
today i could print them out and send
them to you but i didn't bring them with
me if you could email them
i will email them then to the committee
yes thank you networks
any other questions from the committee
seeing none thank you very much thank
you for your time
next the chair will recognize bob lynn
thank you mr chairman um
members of the committee i i when i
signed up to testify i you know said do
you support or oppose and i basically
said i i don't take a position either
way but i am concerned
and and one of the things i hope this
committee will do i
i i want to emphasize here that i am not
suggesting in any way that anybody
um you know has has
has sort of tried to mislead you at all
i don't mean i have great respect for
everybody that's testified here but it
sounds like
you've gotten
really kind of conflicting numbers
on
whether they're you know whether it has
taken longer for cases to be
disposed of under the old system or
under the new system and i'm
you know again i have no doubt that the
people who have given you this
information have given you to given you
what they honestly believe is true but
it sounds like
you know we're not maybe they're not
exactly on the same page and i hope that
the members of the committee
will sort of
you know in your work sessions or in
follow-up will ask them to kind of
you know
get those numbers together so to speak
so that you have a you have an accurate
picture of whether things really are
taking longer
under the new system
than under the old system um i i have
some i have some real question about
that but you know i don't i i'm not in
the court system anymore and i don't and
i don't really know but i hope that you
will find out because it seems to me
that that's as as i think
representatives who people who have
testified here both in support of and in
opposition
to
the proposed bill have said
it's really important i think for the
committee
to rely not on sort of anecdotal
you know things are taking longer or
things are being more efficient but
really looking at the numbers of what
what those what those numbers show
um
the the other thing that i would that so
i hope that you will do that
it i must say that it sounds to me like
from
what we've heard from both
people who have testified in favor of
this and and in opposition is that
one thing that i hope the committee will
at least consider as a possible
way of
of of
resolving this
is per you know to the extent that the
claim has been that
because there's no sort of automatic
right to a probable cause hearing
under the news under the felonies first
system
the lack of that
sort of stick you know that there's
there's going to be a probable cause
hearing on this date as as i think
everybody has sort of agreed
my understanding is that like under the
old system 87 or 85 to 87 percent of
those probable cause hearings never
occurred they the the because either the
case was resolved or the purpose of
of the defendant in requesting the
probable cause hearing
um was to get was to get um
uh discovery and once discovery was got
there once discovery was had they they
sort of waved the probable cause hearing
to the extent that that
is not happening under the current
system
um
you know maybe maybe that is a maybe
that would be a way of
of uh
helping to to move things along so to
speak in the superior court but in other
words
change the change the requirement to
make the probable cause hearing sort of
automatic unless it's waived in the
superior court now
as i say that i'm sure richard head is
sitting behind me saying wait a minute
that's going to involve a tremendous
amount of work and i know that that that
that would include that would
potentially at least increase the work
in the uh in the superior court and
obviously if that were to happen you
know there's going to be a there's a
resource issue there that would
um
would arise but perhaps there's some way
to work out language that would
you know would condition
the sort of automatic right to a
probable cause hearing in the superior
court on
um
the defendant you know certifying that
he has not yet that he is by some time
frame that he has not received all
discovery that he's entitled to or
whatever and and if that's usually the
reason that that the you know the
probable cause hearing is sort of
insisted upon is kind of as as as a
stick by the defense to make sure they
get discovery maybe there could be some
language that would that would uh
would would condition the right on on
the defendant say certifying that he has
not
received uh complete discovery or or
something like that
the last point i would make and i think
this is really
a really very important point is this
it then i hope the committee will
consider is this
the right time even if
a change back to the old system
is the right thing to do
is this the time to do it and i say that
because my understanding is
i think you've sort of heard this from
from mr head and really others this
whole covert thing has had a huge impact
on the trial courts both the superior
court and the and the uh and the circuit
court
and
to make a change now
to you know to sort of say we're going
to put
to go back to the old system is going to
involve a huge undertaking of work i
mean in in terms of what the court
system is going to have to go through
it's yes yes they're for you know they
know how it how it worked before
and they can make the changes to to to
return it to what to what it was but
that involves a lot of work
and it involves it will involve a lot of
work
at a time when the court system
is really struggling so i hope you'll
you know one of the things you will ask
yourself is
is this the right time to do this even
if
it's something that you know eventually
should be done um
i i hope you'll you'll consider that uh
that's that's really all i have to say
and i thank you for giving me the
opportunity to to appear i'm happy to
answer any questions if anyone has any
questions for representative lynn now we
have a yes representative dilorenzo
thank you mr claire um representative
lynn i read in the newspaper that a lot
of jurisdictions have um
suspended jury trials temporarily
do you have any data on that so we could
get a sense of
you know what the difference is
between before code and and like well i
think while we're included thank you i i
i can't really give you statistics i
mean but i my understanding is that many
many courts
around the country at least for periods
of time
um did suspend
you know jury trials in fact maybe even
more and maybe even you know
many other court proceedings except
probably emergency things
of
things like that but um so i think that
that's true my understanding is that the
you know new hampshire also the superior
court suspended jury trials for a period
of time i don't i don't have the exact
dates but i know that that that that did
happen
um
and i say and i think that's you know
that new hampshire wasn't unique in that
regard at all but i in terms of how long
uh i i just haven't kind of kept up on
that on that information but um but
perhaps mr head could give you that or
i'm sure we you know that could be
provided to the committee if you if you
any further questions
see you none thank you very much thank
good morning
my name is len harden i'm a
trial lawyer up in northern new
hampshire i've been up there for my
entire career i've been up north for 29
years which is
surprising when i did the math just now
to realize how long i've been doing this
i'm here on behalf of myself as a solo
practitioner
i do exclusively criminal defense i also
hear i've been on the board for the new
hampshire association of criminal
defense lawyers for
i didn't do the math for over 10 years
and we also are in support of this bill
which is um in and i would i'm not gonna
re
recount any of the issues that some of
my colleagues who i have great respect
for have already gone over
um
but i i guess
one of the reasons and i certainly
support what they say and i would agree
with attorney moyer that in my personal
experience i believe at least half of my
cases have resolved
in district court that were brought as
felonies
i did want to share a couple of very
short anecdotal cases
that i think are helpful to understand
what type of cases we're talking about
so i had a
um
a case in in haverhill in grafton county
where um a woman who had been a candidly
a victim of domestic abuse for a long
long time
picked up a board
and and defended herself when she was
being attacked and she used a weapon and
she caused an injury so she was in
under the felony's first regime she was
charged with a felony for causing bodily
injury to that
honestly the violent person
and it took an inordinate
amount of time and it took a lot of work
because the local police knew that the
boyfriend was a bad man
and they knew his history
but again the the way that that gets
communicated to the county attorney i
believe is through an email through an
indirect channel and the lack of local
hands-on
boots on the ground kind of information
is really what caused that to be a great
delay another case that i see typically
is
possession of drugs which we we all
recognize as a scourge but again the in
the cases that i have seen
over and over again these types of cases
where somebody gets stopped for a
typical motor vehicle violation one case
that i'm thinking of in particular
a gentleman had a pill crusher which
essentially is has residue of a pill and
it allows somebody to snort the pill
that's the purpose of the thing is um so
he gets charged with a felony and it
goes up to the district court and they
and
er
in days gone by that case would go to
the district court we would meet with
the prosecutor the prosecutor would be
either a police prosecutor or a lawyer
they would get permission from the
county attorneys to resolve the case and
we would resolve that case almost
uniformly that case would get resolved
now that case goes up to the superior
court and it takes a lot longer for the
case to get hurt and to get a resolution
and ultimately it it still should be and
it probably will always be a misdemeanor
for a first offense for that person and
it should be
but it takes longer and it takes more
time
the the one thing that i wanted to bring
up that i don't think has been touched
on a lot is the issue about recidivism
and why and how that
is going in my opinion would be better
served by going back to the 2015 method
so there are sorts all sorts of studies
and i'll leave that to you folks to to
delve into about the quicker a person
gets into treatment
the more effective that treatment is and
and that's why another reason why it's
very important that we we look at the
timeline and how quickly these things
occur
but by getting somebody
put onto probation mandated to go to
counseling mandated to get an alcohol
drug evaluation mandated to get on on
the road to recovery sooner has a bigger
impact it also psychologically helps
when somebody says oh my goodness i just
got charged with a crime i've never been
charged with a crime before and now i'm
in court and then all of a sudden two
weeks later i'm on probation they take
it very seriously if it takes a
prolonged period of time that same
person doesn't have the same impetus to
participate and they don't get the same
benefit out of
um out of the shock and the and the
scare
quite candidly um
but
the the
felonies person and anecdotally again in
my experience
has certainly slowed down the process it
it
the lack of local control and lack of
input also i think has an impact on
treatment
and the impact that it has on the actual
defendants who were who were hopefully
going to turn into
and help
turn their lives around in a positive
the the other
thought that i would like to share with
the committee would be um
just just to echo what other folks have
said that when we when we try to solve a
problem
um
and you're looking at it either
either it is or it isn't it seems like
this is the the classic if you're a
hammer and you ask someone how to fasten
a board together you look for a nail and
you don't look for the screw um and in
in this case i think
the felonies first
um
is looking for a solution that like
attorney moyer said wasn't a problem the
the system
there are going to be 2 000 cases or
whatever the number of cases are
either in the district court or in the
superior court and certainly i would
echo everybody's sentiment that the
district court's much more nimble and
more capable and i would say in my
experience
that the district court has much more
common sense
appeal
from the judges from the local police
prosecutors and not not disparaging my
county attorney friends i think that
they've also worked in the district
court but they see the pragmatic
solutions that people can come up with
which are very unique and i think very
special to new hampshire so for all
those reasons i certainly support this
bill
and the organization that i support
great any questions for attorney hardin
seeing none thank you very much thank
you simone
mr chairman members of the committee uh
good morning still um my name is frank
knack i'm the policy director with the
aclu of new hampshire
um
we are we are here in support of this
bill uh we thank uh the chairman for
bringing this bill and also you know
support everything and all the data that
mr hawks outlined and so i don't want to
repeat what's already been said i do
want to build upon a few a few notes
that have been mentioned i think it was
the merrimack county attorney who
mentioned that
looking at you know the causes of
backlog and was it an increase in crimes
and i think it was he had testified that
he had not seen an increase of crimes in
his county and so i actually pulled the
uh state data for crimes and arrests
from 2017 through 2020 and what you
actually see is a steady decline in
crimes group a crimes so between 2017
and 2019 which is pre-coveted the three
pre-covered years you saw an 11 decline
in crimes committed this is group a
crimes
and then a 10 decrease in arrests and so
any notion that there was an increase of
arrest or increase of crimes as a cause
of the backlog i think wouldn't be
supported and if you fast forward to
2020 which i think is somewhat skewed
because of covid you're down to a 22
decline in crime rates
for those for that period
in addition i think there's been a lot
of talk about efficiency and you know
making sure that
i think one of the one of the county
attorneys testified that you know the
process there would be a lot of time in
retraining and creating new processes
and going back to the old system and i
think you know what what our concern is
obviously we like this bill because it
would bring back some due process
protections ensuring that people get a
pc hearing
dealing with the backlog that's
impacting people's lives on a daily
basis and their families and their
communities
but also if if we're serious about
actually understanding you know the the
root causes of why we have backlogs we
should look at and i think there are a
number of bills before this legislative
body this session that actually address
the causes of why we have backlogs you
know defelonizing all drug possession
there is legislation before this body
that would do that that would reduce
crime we should look at data-driven ways
to reduce
the burden on our courts and i think
there's many opportunities before this
legislative body this session to do so
any questions
seeing none
the chair now recognizes mark
sisti
did i get that correct
i did great
welcome good morning thank you for
by introduction my name is mark sisti
i'm a criminal defense attorney in the
state of new hampshire i'm licensed in
other states as well
but i primarily practice in new
hampshire
i started in 1979
as a public defender
and
actually worked through the system there
ended up being the deputy director of
the public defenders worked homicides
tried a lot of cases a lot of places
but i've been hearing about this bill
and i was quite interested in it and
i've been listening to the testimony
this morning
about the good old days and uh and
what's going on right now
the first time i stood up
for an accused citizen in the state of
new hampshire was in portsmouth district
court when it was located
not where it is now but in a police
station
and i'm sure anybody familiar with what
the area would know it was a pretty
interesting place
it hearkened back to you know the 1800s
it was a probable cause hearing
and it was for an individual that i can
i can remember your first one you never
forget
and uh he was charged with eight
burglaries
and they were all felonies obviously
the probable cause hearing went on
an hour and a half
probable cause was found
but during the course of the probable
cause hearing serious flaws with regard
to this individual's confession were
exposed
because of that particular information
that was gained during the course of an
actual hearing
with actual witnesses in an actual
courtroom
the case was later dropped
and the felonies were resolved
now that's not
that's not an uncommon situation
the importance of a probable cause
hearing and the importance of the way
the structure was
prior to the felony's first
introduction
was that it gave
opportunities for lawyers
and prosecutors to find out what the
case is about
now whether or not whether or not no
probable cause was found is an issue
whether or not the individual
should be treated with regard to a
lesser offense could be addressed
whether or not bail could be addressed
all of these issues are very very
important they're more important than
dollar signs and quite frankly they're
more important than ringing our hands
and saying we have to go back to the old
days
the old days weren't bad
the old days survived for decades and
decades and decades
it wasn't the prosecutors in this state
it wasn't the criminal defense bar in
this state that came to you on their
knees begging for a change
we were working well within that system
and the examples go on and on
if you if you bring criminal defense
attorneys and prosecutors into this room
and ask them about how resolution took
place
prior to this new institution that we're
dealing with they will tell you story
after story now that's not a statistic
but it's a reality
these are individuals that work every
day in the system
and it happened time after time after
time where resolutions were found
not just in burglary cases
but i mean i can go through a long list
i have practiced law in every district
court in this state
i have tried jury trials in every
superior court in this state
and i can tell you
that the old system worked
it even worked
with murder cases
probable cause hearings on murder cases
could expose problems with murder cases
where an attorney general's office would
look at flaws during that particular
proceeding and make a charging decision
different than the original charging
decision
which would resolve the case quickly and
efficiently
without rendering this
lag
that takes place at superior court right
now
interestingly enough
i was i was focused on the testimony of
the county attorney from belknap county
a friend of mine
and an individual that i work with all
um
i completed a uh
com
fairly complex aggravated felonious
sexual assault in belknap county
recently and i can tell you something
that this felony's first business
delayed that case over
and over
and over again during the course of the
trial
what would have or should have taken
three days was in belknap county as we
call it belknap county time
when we are asked when we are asked to
estimate the length
of trial in belknap county the judge
asks us that question
and we say generally we say the reality
time would be about three days
but belknap county time is about seven
days
and why is it seven days
because it's a one judge court
it's a one judge court and they don't
know what their dock is going to be from
day to day
they have no idea
who got picked up the night before
and when they when they come into the
courthouse in the morning they take a
look and they say uh oh we got felonies
first
we got one felony first
or we have five felonies first well you
also have a jury sitting there
that has to be there too
so what are they doing in the afternoon
while you're going through felonies
first
they're doing nothing
and how is the case proceeding that you
started trying in the morning
it's not
so if you want to talk about
efficiencies
and you want to talk about
ways of getting things moving quicker
it's the old way
it's not that hard to go back to it
and any practitioner that's been
practicing
throughout the years with the old system
and the new system will tell you that
more lawyering and more negotiation took
place in the district courts
with police prosecutors
with lawyer trained prosecutors and yes
with county attorneys
telephone calls still exist
police departments can call county
attorneys
if there's a serious offense that takes
place tonight
in belknap county or coast county or
down in nashua
the police department can call a county
attorney out they can inform them what's
going on
they can kick in the services that they
have to kick in at that particular spot
and they can start resolution
but what's going on now
and i think attorney halverson nailed it
it's a it's just a choke point
we're all getting choked
and i hear it from everybody
i mean
i supervised 72 lawyers at the public
defenders randy hawks has twice as many
and i will tell you
i know what the numbers are at the
public defenders now i know because my
daughter worked there for 15 years and
my son-in-law still does
and you are suffocating people in that
system
and and it's because and i'm going to
say this it's the direct result
of this change
it has slowed the process and it is
grinding people up
and i'm going to urge you i'm going to
ask you i almost beg you
that you when you consider this
that you take a hard look at what it's
doing to the entire process across the
board
people were happier in the system
defendants were given more protection in
the system
and it ran smoothly
prior to the introduction of felonies
first
and with that
uh obviously you know i support the bill
i'll take questions representative
horrigan
you mentioned belknap county time and i
apologize i missed
i was
introducing a bill on another committee
so i apologize for missing your
at least part of your testimony
with belknap county which has a one
judge court do they bring in an
additional judge for uh
belnov county several times a year has
you know mass gatherings they have the
bike week
well most years and they have also the
concert
venue in guilford and i assume a large
number of people get picked up for minor
misdemeanors for misbehaving while
they're enjoying the concert so did they
bring in extra
judges on occasions like that or is it
even more gridlocked on after those
events than it would be normally well i
mean
andrew can speak to that as well but uh
it's it's not really a regular
occurrence judges are brought in
uh on occasion um it's it's not
something that is uh actually even
scheduled where we would know when we're
having to judge
a courthouse but
the timing you know just because you
have a concert on one night doesn't mean
that your cases are going to load the
next day
but
the interesting thing is it's a great
point that if you have a concert and you
have a mass arrest on one night and
they're brought to a
courthouse a circuit court
the next day yes what would happen
in the new system
attorneys would be assigned
the process would begin and early
resolution could take place that's not
any further questions
seeing none thank you very much for your
testimony
the last pin card i have in house bill
1597 is from alan
my name is alan kroenheim and i'm also a
criminal defense lawyer i
work in portsmouth
and uh
i'm gonna while most of my work is in
stratford and rockingham county i'll
just focus on rockingham county for the
moment
using the statistics
that have already been referenced
roughly 25 percent of the cases under
the old system
filed in rockingham county were resolved
in the district courts what does that
mean
so for
every 75 cases that the county
attorney's office used to have they now
have 100 cases
what does that mean for the superior
court well
to process
a case in superior court there are
usually two or three people in the
clerk's office who touch the file
there are then two or three
administrators
support staff in the county attorney's
office who touches the file
there's the reviewing
lawyer who assigns the case in the
county attorney's office
the assigned lawyer in the county
attorney's office
and the supervising lawyer in the county
and then these felonies even if they are
at some point reduced to misdemeanors
these felonies get presented to the
grand jury because there's a right to
indictment within 90 days
the grand jury is 23 people
and
then there are the judges who were
assigned to initial hearings and then
dispositional hearings and status
conferences
in many of my cases it's two judges
which means
also two deputy clerks who are touching
a case
so what that means is that if you're
bringing a felony case
there are between 30 and 40 people who
alternately
if a case was resolved in the district
court while there are people from the
clerk's office and the police prosecutor
involved
the numbers are dramatically different
as it relates to the impact on the local
police department to indict typically
there is one or two police officers
who are going to the grand jury to
present testimony to them
so as a management system
you are creating a process
of 30 to 40 people touching the file
that eventually is resolved in 25 of the
cases as a misdemeanor
as a management construct
it just doesn't make sense
in
full disclosure
i
representing new hampshire association
of criminal defense lawyers
years ago
testified against felonies first
our prediction was it would not work
it would create
enormous greater case loads for county
attorneys
it would result in a slower average time
for resolution of cases
and that information is accurate and
true
i have great respect for
attorney head who i've not seen for
years
the information that he presented to you
today is exactly the information that we
disputed
when
felonies first was proposed
years ago
the information that
randy hawks is presented to you is from
statistics analyzing case by case
information
we could never get the information the
underlying information as to how the
court
came up with this 323 days it might have
been based on
limited
cases that were resolved as felonies
that then necessarily deleted the
misdemeanors resolved in the district
court that had been originally charged
as felonies
well i don't always agree with judge
lynn i sure agree with him now find out
where this information is coming from
test the statistics i want to go back to
just a couple points quickly that have
been made
in terms of victim services it is
absolutely true that every county
attorney's office has
assistance for victims
it is also the case in many many police
departments and in virtually every
district court there are victim witness
advocates there too
there was conversation by attorney head
about the possibility of cases being
pled down and
returned to the district court i can
just tell you in rockingham county that
just does not happen
my cases which used to take four to six
months to resolve i will tell you cases
that are now being addressed as
misdemeanors in the end are taking nine
months to a year
part of what's going on
is that we have
requested of the county attorney's
office that they deal with the serious
as well as the minor
and in dealing with the minor they are
less attentive to the serious ones as
well
i i did a 10-day jury trial
where it was a serious case involved a
gun
the prosecutor had to be involved in
dealing with other minor misdemeanors as
we were doing the trial
as a citizen i would prefer the county
attorney's office to
focus on the serious
and let the misdemean the lesser cases
that can be addressed as misdemeanor let
them be resolved
in the district court so the county
attorney's office the best trained as
attorney liver noise said the best
trained the most experienced
are focusing on the
cases that create harm to our community
a point that i think attorney liver
noise misses
is
that
under the old system there was always
concurrent jurisdiction
between the district court and the
superior court for felonies
so to the point he was concerned about
his
experienced prosecutors couldn't get a
case quickly
it is the case under the old law and it
should be the case if there are changes
now
that a case can be felt uh filed in
either court
so if he has a concern that he wants a
case
a sexual assault a serious weapons
charge
he can talk with the police department
instantly and say
let's file it in the superior court not
the district court
so that concern can be fully addressed
there's been some
conversation about the impact of delayed
treatment it is the case that with the
delay
in resolution of cases whether it's
alcohol or drugs or mental health we're
not letting or getting people into
treatment now
we're doing it months later sometimes
when
other greater difficulties
have occurred
the court system said
years ago
that police departments would be trained
to file the lesser cases not as felonies
but as misdemeanors and that simply has
not occurred and isn't the way the
charging decisions are made
when somebody's picked up at midnight
by a police officer with two or three
years experience that officer is not
going to choose to charge
a felony drug case small as it may be as
a misdemeanor
that will be charged as a felony and
away we go to the superior court
so the idea that there will be
differing judgments in the charging
process
is not
the case in the real world
it is my hope
that you will take
this bill seriously it would be an
important improvement in the court
system
providing prompter justice in a fairer
way
thank you thank you and do we have any
questions or we do from representative
chase
mr chair and thank you for taking my
question so what is actually stopping
the police from
filing a misdemeanor are you just saying
that it's the younger
rookie cops that are doing this well
in truth the decisions should be made to
my view knowing more about the defendant
than you know at the time of the arrest
so
it could be a drug case really should be
a felony or maybe it should be a
misdemeanor at midnight we don't know
what that individual's prior record is
we don't know whether it's a drug
dealing case or a drug possession case
so i think it's completely appropriate
to charge those cases as felonies it's
just once that's done
away we go to superior court and so when
the
court administration
was supporting this bill years ago they
were making the claim which i think is
not a claim in the real world
that these
felonies would simply be charged as
misdemeanors that's not the way i think
real decision making
gets done
because you would want to know something
about the case and you would want to
know something about the defendant
further questions for the attorney
seeing none thank you very much for your
testimony
is there anyone else in the room who
wishes to testify on house bill
seeing none that i will call this
hearing the house bill 1597 to a close
and we are running about a half hour
behind
so we'll
press right on
to house bill
1014.
sure
oh
oh yeah
we did i'm glad i'm glad you did thank
you for introducing me
you were offended that court system was
affected in this
steve
oh
we'll call the house judiciary committee
back to order
our next item of business this morning
is a hearing on house bill 1014 allowing
public meetings to be conducted
virtually
the primary sponsor of that bill is
representative simpson
and we'll call upon her to introduce the
thank you mr chair
and thank you committee members for
hearing me introduce this bill this
morning
the circumstances of the pandemic and
the emergency order regarding public
meetings allowed us to see what might be
possible for the effective functioning
of democracy with the use of technology
for meetings
throughout the emergency order we saw
overwhelming support by the public for
remote access to public meetings
i've also heard from many town officials
that they found the use of remote
meetings allowed for broader stakeholder
participation which makes their work
more effective
and i realize now i forgot to say that i
represent the towns of exeter new market
new fields and stratum
i reside in exeter
and my name is alexis simpson for the
record
i know last year when we discussed
remote meetings in the committee there
were some concerns
in this bill i attempted to correct for
the concerns raised this is a narrow
narrower bill than previous remote
meetings bills
it simply allows towns municipalities
and public state bodies
to choose to meet virtually or offer a
remote option to its members
the bill allows this by adding rules
that must be met by the public body
under the right to know laws in rsa 91a
hb 1014 provides direction for public
notice
and public access both to virtual
meetings
and to meetings with an option for
remote attendance under the right to
know law
the bill makes it clear that if there is
a physical meeting location there does
not have to be a remote option
it gives the authority to decide whether
a meeting will be remote
to the public body
not to an individual member of the body
which just as a side note the house has
decided in its rules
not to take this option
this bill would give other bodies in the
state the option to take it if they
desired
this bill also addresses online chat
functions that we've spoken about before
by treating them the same way that rsa
91a treats email correspondence
access to remote state and local
meetings during the pandemic was
necessary for granite staters to stay
safe but it continues to be necessary
for those who experience barriers to
accessing in-person meetings
under regular non-pandemic conditions
those who have disabilities those who
have young children elderly citizens and
those who can't drive at night or in the
snow have all shared with me how
important remote access is to them
these are just some of the people who
are able to participate more fully in
without adapting language in rsa 91a the
statute regarding the right to know laws
government bodies at the town
municipalities and state level are no
longer able to choose a remote meeting
option
and the public is no longer able to
participate in meetings remotely
this bill would give government bodies
who wish the option
to do so
i hope you will hear testimony from
towns and from the nhma who supports
this bill they will um
also talk a bit about towns they
represent i hope
that having this would make a difference
to their members in conducting business
thank you and i'll take questions now
are there any questions for
representative wolper did you have a
question uh thank you mr chairman and
is there a required physical location
for a meeting if you're holding it
remotely
not in this bill no
there is an option for a fully virtual
so if you have
thought yep
if you're having a
remote meeting do you have to allow
i believe that most of the bodies decide
um
how and how to do public input
so i don't know that that's part of
asrsa rsa 91a that would require public
input at all bodies that meet i'm not
sure that's part of
i don't i am unclear
if the answer to your question is
answered in 10 14.
you may follow yeah that'd be helpful
actually
thank you if you can clarify one more
it's my understanding that the reason we
have public meetings
is for the public to be able to
interface
with their
elected officials or whoever
if the meeting is totally remote
isn't public input
remotely
a necessary part of that yes yes so my
understanding is that requirement is not
changed by this piece of
legislation does that make sense so it's
still required to have public input but
if that's not
representative welber if that's not it's
my understanding that's built into the
rsa that that public input is required
regardless of whether the meeting
happens virtually or in person
if that's unclear
then i'm
open to adding an amendment that would
make that clear
that there would be the same requirement
for public input
if the meeting is remote that there is
a parody do you know what i'm saying
that there be the same requirement for
public input
at a remote meeting as there would be
for an in-person meeting
does that make sense
we'll come back okay okay representative
representative sylvia
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
um
so
91a is in support of uh our
constitutional
constitution part first article 8 which
demands transparency
if a meeting is totally remote
how much transparency
is there
if
for instance
members of whatever that public body
is
are
texting to one another um outside of the
the
normal channel whatever channel it is
for the
phone interface
i have not thought about texting
um
but i don't know how that would
differ
whether
a body is in person or whether they are
remote
follow up
would you believe that if people were
texting in this room i would
perhaps have an idea in fact the the
um i would i would not necessarily
believe that
because i think it's not
clear
what a person is doing behind their
computer or behind their phone
so in my estimation i think it'd be hard
or i'll speak for myself it would be
hard for me to know whether someone was
texting or with their child who had
missed the bus or
with another person
in the meeting
thank you
other questions representative horrigan
yes thank you very much um
i think i think this bill makes some
makes
uh makes a
provision for
non-public meetings of the public body
because uh which are appropriate under a
variety of specified
circumstances so does this allow
[Music]
does this
does this would this allow
non-public meetings if the public body
i believe that it is addressed in an
earlier
or part of 91a
what uh those meetings happening
telephonically or electronically that's
addressed i believe elsewhere okay
thanks and
um
okay are there other questions
representative wolper did you have
further
too busy
representative
chase you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question out of curiosity
because we just had a meeting last night
for our uh county and i don't even know
if we had enough for a quorum some were
zooming in
no we didn't unfortunately
others were there physically how is that
going to affect
this bill when it comes to having to
vote and having your correct quorum
thank you for asking that is actually
one of the biggest impetuses for this
bill is
um
bodies who are having
meetings with a physical location
and having some people having to zoom in
or to call in or
uh
electronically
allowing for there to be a quorum made
by those who are in the physical
location and
who are participating remotely
because it
any other question representative sylvia
thank you ms chairman uh thank you for
taking my further question
so
public access to these
remote meetings
what would happen in the case which
we've experienced where there's a storm
there are power failures
part of your citizenry may not be able
to
attend or
have access
so there's a requirement if somebody is
unable to attend
that they be in touch with there's a it
has to be stated where they um contact
someone to say
that they are unable to access um the
remote
option in the meeting
but
beyond
that
i think
the same
provision would be made that is made now
for
folks who can't attend meetings
because of
similar circumstances or other
if half the town loses power
i think your public body is going to
make a particular decision about a
meeting
right
they'll do the same thing i would
suppose if there's a remote
option thank you
for the questions
i usually don't have a volume problem
i'm representative stephen smith
sullivan county district 11 the towns of
akworth charlestown goshen langdon
webster and washington
so before i decide if a bill is a good
idea or not i apply it to three
standards is it implementable affordable
and enforceable
this one's not the first and the last
and i have no idea about the second
so here's technical problem number one
if there is a problem with access
the media if the meeting shall be
adjourned
okay
so
let's let's just do a use case on that
you are all on your county delegations
and you're painfully aware
of the labyrinth of deadlines you have
for your budget convention
you present the budget you have a
certain number of days to act on the
budget now if you were to have to do a
couple of meetings in there you would be
unable to comply with the notice
requirements of 91a which are not
suspended by this bill so you got to
give them five days notice
so you're acting on the budget and let's
assume you've gotten way ahead of your
work that's awesome and you have six or
seven days to go
a guy from tuscaloosa calls in and says
i can't access the feed
i can't connect to the meeting you are
adjourned the minute that happens public
isn't defined
how many people isn't defined the minute
gary from oklahoma calls in and says
i can't access the meeting you're done
you're adjourned not reassessed not on a
break to address it
that's it
so that that's poorly thought out
i don't know what the number is do you
as a localized outage okay i don't know
when the bill doesn't tell me does it
have to be 30 or 40 people i don't know
so
adjourned no no good and who is the
public
have you considered that
we've seen examples where we have
disruptors at public meetings who go
there and
engage in shenanigans to try to shut
things down this bill is a fantastic
mechanism for people to do exactly that
particularly where a public body is up
against a deadline you have folks call
in and say
i can't access the meeting and you also
haven't provided a mechanism to deal
with that
so the minute they notify you you're
done
i know this doesn't apply to the house
but imagine mr chairman you are
painfully aware of the ridiculous
deadlines that you have to comply with
for report out dates and imagine how
easy it would be to just have every bill
in this committee die by folks reporting
outage problems
so what happens when the person calls in
with an access problem
is it your problem is it their problem
or does nothing happen does the meeting
just end and then be subject to another
91 91a required notification period i
so the the implementable and enforceable
part
those are just non-starters now
affordable so do you have to give the
folks tech support
if somebody calls in and says i'm trying
to access your zoom meeting or your
microsoft teams meeting or your go to
meeting meeting or whatever it is that
you've chosen to use
one county was actually
streaming their meetings live on
facebook and taking comments and ask
questions what if somebody had a problem
with that or a slow connection when they
call in
what happens what literally happens i
don't know and the bill doesn't tell me
just if they're having trouble accessing
if you get a nice laptop and a good
connection
all of this probably seems really easy
i know people that don't have that that
live in rural areas
that use track phones where they pay for
every minute are we really going to
create a situation where you know what
the weather's lousy select board's going
to stay home tonight and do this puppy
completely virtually and a person is
going to have to literally spend money
to attend that meeting because there are
people that pay for every minute or make
a decision that i'm not going to call my
family a lot or make the other phone
calls because i'm going to use the 60
minutes that i have to attend this
meeting please do not
allow any public body in new hampshire
create a situation where somebody can
literally be forced to pay money to
participate in a public meeting that is
offensive
that reason alone you should itl the
bill
the last thing i'll leave you with is
i've done committee trainings for new
legislators in the past and one of the
things i tell them is that
we all volunteered to do this and what
we are are public servants and literally
the very least that we can do for the
public
is to go someplace where if they have no
money or electronics or means
we will sit before them where they can
look at us and give them our 100 percent
undivided attention face-to-face because
that's what they deserve thank you mr
chair
questions for representative smith no
thank you
representative sylvia do you have any
questions uh
i've said what i needed to say today
thank you mr chair you don't wish to
take questions i do not
representative jake bear and that
sorry about that i'm here not just
representing new futures but the
thousands of individuals across the
state who don't feel that they can
safely access the legislature or make
their voices heard at public hearings
like this
under the current pandemic
i've passed around uh written testimony
i won't repeat too much of that i do
want to address some of the points that
have been made
first off i would say that this bill is
not requiring anybody to meet remotely
it is simply giving the option i know
that this august body made the decision
recently not to
enact a remote option or to allow people
to participate remotely i think
communities around the state are just
looking for the same option
and to be able to make that choice for
themselves
secondly i will say that
many of these technical challenges that
representative smith just highlighted
our communities have spent the last year
figuring much of this out they many of
them did move to remote meetings out of
necessity
some of them would like to continue that
they have figured out how to make this
work for their communities
i
thirdly i would like to point out
representative smith i certainly
mentioned you know we certainly
appreciate we as advocates as members of
the public appreciate the time and
attention uh that you give to us during
these hearings in person uh but there
are many people who are not able to get
here as representative simpson mentioned
in her introduction we have elderly and
disabled people who don't have access to
transportation we have working people
who have work conflicts who are not able
to get here or to their public town
meetings as well we have individuals who
can't get child care these are people
who are so directly impacted by the
policies that this body
weighs every day and they cannot get
here to make their voice heard in person
uh enacting remote options to be able to
participate from home would make it much
easier for them to make their voices
heard and be part of this legislative
process we hear from them every day
um
again they would like nothing more than
to be here and speak before you but they
they just can't make it work uh
some of the some of the concerns some of
the obstacles that we're seeing under
the current pandemic with any luck will
fade away soon but those economic
demographic geographic challenges won't
so we we support the spill we ask that
you give it more consideration
one thing i will ask is that if you do
decide to move forward with your
contemplation of this bill uh in the
case that
uh we there is a physical location for a
meeting
and there is a remote but members have
the remote option to participate we ask
that you consider adding language that
we extend the same courtesy to the
public allowing the public to
participate virtually in the case of a
meeting where there is a physical
location
thank you and i'm happy to take
questions
representative honor
thank you mr chairman
um are you aware that
members of the public who can't come
physically can send us an email call us
or drop us a letter in the mail like
they always have before coven
certainly so but you know has been
mentioned several times this morning
that um
i won't say face-to-face contact but you
know
you see the value of face-to-face
contact now while virtual access may not
replicate that entirely i think that
there is the opportunity virtually to
express um
a sort of emotion direct connection to
an issue that you're not able to do over
the phone or through written testimony
but certainly i understand the options
representative horgan did you have a
question um yes one thing i found
when we're doing the remote meetings in
20 20 20 20 21 that it was easier for uh
was easier for handicapped individuals
to participate they were not at a
disadvantage compared with others
although maybe we could have made it
better for people who were sight
impaired
my question
and this may be like a subject for a
different bill but do you think it'd be
worthwhile to add something that said
physical locations for meetings should
certainly i i imagine uh that's that's
addressed in different uh different
parts of statute but certainly i think
that ensuring that our meetings are
accessible uh physically uh to to
everyone is certainly an important point
to be addressed either through this
elsewhere um and with communities you
serve many of them are of limited means
and uh the deputy speaker did speak very
eloquently about those who have limited
means um
what can be done to make sure that
people who don't have a fancy laptop or
can still uh at least
at least still zoom in or use another
software
to attend the meeting so first thank you
for the question representative uh
first i'd love to make the point i think
that many individuals who are
at least able to afford the technology
to be able to zoom into meetings or
participate virtually are likely those
who are least able to get to concord to
attend meetings as well
and may be true to get to their own town
halls or local meetings again due to
work conflicts lack of child care so on
and so forth um but that said you know i
think that uh
you know i think some of the greatest
challenges are not just in individuals
uh the technology that an individual has
at home but overall broadband access or
internet access and communities and i
know that there's a you know great
effort
uh uh you know through federal arpa
funds and other uh you know other uh
funding sources to be able to address
that so i think that honestly is likely
the biggest obstacle to people being
able to in regards to connectivity in
the state uh that's something we're
working on and we'll need to continue to
work on but
again certainly i mean not everybody has
a brand new shiny laptop but again i
would say those who are uh face those
those technology challenges are often
the ones who face the greatest
challenges in getting into meetings in
any other questions
seeing none
representative lorenzo thank you mr
chairman um
thinking about um broadband and computer
access for different communities um
do you think that
with the
computer programs in school where kids
can bring like
you know ipads home
so
do you think it's worth exploring how
many
people
or how many families
participated in that type of program to
just get an idea of who has broadband
and who doesn't
yeah
certainly i think that could be a
sort of important important information
source i think they're all they're
programs like that not just through
schools but through community libraries
as well uh
so yes i think that that's a a great way
to be able to sort of begin to assess
what uh the technology techno
technological capacities of individuals
and families are across the state um but
i think to that point through sort of
lending programs like that uh technology
is available and and you know whether
it's take-home technology through ipads
and so on or it's computers available at
libraries there are i think that once
you open the door to remote access there
are ways to bridge that divide and make
that happen uh in a way that's easier to
than than
enabling everybody to make it to an
in-person meeting here or at other
public office settings
other questions
seeing them thank you thank you very
much
uh thank you mr chair i uh it was
wanting to get down to another hearing
so i appreciate you having me up now i'm
representative jess edwards
i represent auburn chester and sandown
and um as i read this bill and as as
i've listened to the prior testimony
it strikes me
that
we're conflating
two different populations that we really
ought to hold distinct
we have
most of this law which is intended to
address
the the public body meaning you know the
elected or appointed individuals who
have uh
responsibilities to the public
and the public itself
and so um
i i think we can probably all agree
that we like the idea of transparency i
i think section one article eight of our
constitution encourages us to be as
transparent as we can with the public
and so um so given that we have so much
experience with the technology i think i
think it's great to the extent that we
uh people can uh different districts can
afford it
uh to go ahead and
broadcast it so that the public can uh
see what's happening
the the issue i run into though is um
watching
the behavior
of the general court
in the pandemic versus the general the
behavior of the general court prior to
the pandemic
it validated for me a few truths
is that elected officials are human
as humans we have
social
needs we're social animals
there's a tremendous amount of
communication
socialization
norming
that takes place
in person-to-person interaction
and without that person-to-person
interaction
it's very difficult
to
transmit
a full communication i think
you know communication uh researchers
have indicated that over 50
of what people communicate to one
another is through non-verbal
communication the intonation of their
vote voice their their body language um
just just their mannerisms
are as much as the communication process
as the the words
and um because of that i'll just dip for
a moment into
line 23 of page 1
where it says that
if you're if you don't have a physical
location the public could participate by
telephone
and i i would recommend
just generally not
having
telephone be a favored way of
communicating to the public people run
into
attention span issues
you you definitely don't get any of the
non-verbal communication from from body
language and so i just i would just rate
telephone as an inadequate
way of communicating a public body's
meeting to the public
i'd also point out that
the public has a right to peacefully
assemble
and
if i were
someone
running a public meeting and i felt
there was a great deal of public
pressure a lot of anxiety a lot of angst
where the public might want to come
publicly demonstrate
as a way for the public to communicate
with us
i could see
the motivation to go to an all remote
all virtual meeting
because by doing that
you isolate
the public officials from the people
you you don't get you know what my in my
first term i was on health and human
services and we were doing a lot of uh
transgender bills and we would have to
go to rep's hall because
um you'd end up with uh 200 people who
were there
that even if they didn't want to talk
their presence was itself a form of
communication
and if you have if we have virtual
meetings
the public cannot
have that kind of
communication effect of having their
physical mass
present
so so i would think we would be losing
something extremely valuable
uh if we were to go
to allow public meetings to always be
virtual
i
i would also like to point out that in
the existing law
if if a member is unable to participate
in a centralized meeting
there's still a method in the law
for them to get an exemption and just
have the exemption carried over into the
minutes of why they weren't physically
present so it's it's not like we don't
have some flexibility for the
public officials currently in law it's
um
yeah
it it it's there so
um
perhaps
someday when the metaverse is fully
mature
and we can all
you know put on the suits and in in in
the virtual reality kicks in and we can
see
everybody um you know maybe the
technology will be good enough at that
point to uh conduct routinely
our public meetings
virtually but
i don't i don't believe the technology's
there at this point and um
and i and and and i think that part of
being a public official and volunteering
for this job is to realize the demands
that it'll place on you
and be prepared to either meet those
demands or to allow somebody to take
your place
so um
so with that um i'll take questions i'll
even pretend i'm representative smith
and answer questions like i'm him but
i'm kidding steve
are there
questions for representative
edwards you're off the hook all right
good
morning it on now thank you
i haven't been here for a year so um
bear with me um good morning chair
gordon and members of the committee for
the record my name is paulie campion i
am a former state representative a
retired nurse and today i am here
representing the new hampshire nurses
association
in support of hb 1014
as you know this bill does several
things it establishes requirement for
remote access to public meetings
it strikes the requirement for persons
to be present in a specific physical
location
it strikes the determination of an
emergency be made by the chair of the
presiding officer so there are others
who may determine that
and it adds the requirement that public
access can be provided by telephone
video or other means excluding chat
rooms so you know that you've read the
bill
remote access to public meetings was
available
during the pandemic pursuant to
emergency order number 12. and in fact
this bill has many um
components to it that actually look as
if they are similar to that emergency
order many of the provisions
during the state of emergency this
allowed members of the public to
participate safely regardless of their
location
via the use of video or telephone
the significantly reduced barriers to
participation for members of the public
as well as elected officials
nurses throughout the state seek to be
engaged in activities of public bodies
local regional or statewide boards
committees commissions or legislative
bodies
with more than twenty thousand licensed
registered nurses plus another three
thousand plus licensed practical nurses
and untold numbers of licensed nursing
assistants
they work in a wide variety of roles and
institutions
as you can imagine they also bring
a wealth of knowledge and experience to
policy deliberations particularly those
related to a public health emergency
during the pandemic nurses have been
stretched to their limits
and find it increasingly difficult to
carve out time to travel to meetings
that require in-person presence for
participation
rather than being able to take a lunch
break
and tune into a meeting and provide
testimony or offer their opinion
they are not able to participate
and many nurses are hesitant to
participate in indoor gatherings that
may put them at further risk of exposure
as they contemplate further stressing
their own colleagues and health care
agencies already functioning with
limited staff
it's particularly difficult for those
that may be immunocompromised or living
in a great distance
the expiration of the executive order
allowing fully remote meetings of public
bodies has exacerbated the difficulty
that many nurses experience in
participating in the discourse of public
bodies including those of the new
hampshire general court
hb 1014
removing the requirement for a physical
location would allow greater flexibility
for those wishing to participate
creating equity of access between and
among all residents and public office
holders
thank you for your time and attention
and on behalf of the new hampshire
nurses association we encourage you to
vote ought to pass on hb 1014.
you may also have seen that i submitted
on behalf of the
new hampshire state commission on aging
slightly different testimony
and if i might add just a couple of
comments from that body
as i'm as i'm sitting here
i happen to chair the state commission
on aging
we are a combined
body that includes both state agency
representatives as well as members from
from the public subject medic experts
from all 10 counties
we have been unable to
achieve an in-person quorum which in our
particular body would be 13 members we
had had our annual or our monthly
meeting on monday
we had 11 people participating in person
and were unable therefore to
execute on activities
recommendations from the commission
the charge to the commission is to
advise you all
the governor and the general court about
policy matters relating to older adults
and aging policy issues we were unable
to take actions having to do with
transportation which is one of the two
top issues that older adults identify as
challenges that they have
so with that i will i will um take off
both hats um and
i'm available to answer questions if
there are any are there questions for
former representative campion yes
representative smith
thank you mr uh chair it's wonderful to
see you we would like you to be sitting
on this side but that was your choice
um
you say that you submitted testimony to
us from
the commission on aging can you tell me
where or how because i have not seen
such testimony i use the online link
attached document
and hit submit thank you very much
i'm so glad you mentioned that because
we have already inquired today on
the leadership in the in the house
as to
what happens with
materials that go to the portal because
at the moment they seem to go down the
rabbit hole so now we know to look for
it and thank you very much thank you
that's helpful to know there have been
multiple occasions in which uh
colleagues of mine has submitted a
testimony that way so that's interesting
representative horrigan thank you very
much mr chair and thank you very much uh
i still think he was representing
as a as a nurse and as a member of the
commission the agent you deal more with
people who have disabilities than in the
past so if you found that um the remote
technology
enables
populations who
[Music]
can't make it to the state house to
participate because
absolutely and i think it's it's
interesting to
note that those of us who are here to
testify either for or against this bill
um are either
we either have jobs that
include this activity as part of our
role or we're retired in my case
i don't see any people who are working
regular daytime jobs or
conversely are sleeping because they've
worked overnight
follow up please
yep follow up thank you mr chair thank
you uh the honorable
poly campion um
the physical relations this may this may
not be the proper vehicle for the bill
but there are issues with physical
locations not being
accessible to those with handicaps
especially mobility handicaps so
regardless of whether or not we try to
put any language in this bill
what should we do to make the physical
locations more accessible to a wider
population
thank you for that question i think it
probably is beyond the scope of this
this bill
but would absolutely encourage um
particularly all public buildings
um to be
made accessible to those with
other questions representative wolper
uh thank you mr chairman and thank you
was the uh nurses association able to
meet before the pandemic
the well the nurses association
is not a public body
uh we're a membership membership
association and so we do not um suffer
from the restrictions of needing to have
a physical location
um the uh to me
prior to the pandemic we did meet
in a physical location and adjusted
during the pandemic and have been
meeting remotely
um
perhaps i'm confused
i thought you were talking about maybe
you were talking about the council on
aging that was hasn't
is supposed to advise this party but
were they able to meet before the
pandemic
thank you for the question um they were
able to meet before the pandemic and in
part
they were able to meet because the body
was smaller
and they were reimbursed for mileage
which they are not currently the members
were reimbursed for their mileage which
they are currently not um
able to do and the membership has
expanded to include people who um for
instance we have a ceo of a as a member
of a community health center
in coast county
as you can imagine during the pandemic
it's hard for him to carve out time
to attend a two-hour meeting on a monday
morning
between and among all of his other other
duties i hear your question though
you're asking what's the change and in
fact the the challenge
existed prior to the pandemic the
ability of members of the public to
participate in public bodies
and or those
members of the public who sought to take
on
roles as members of public bodies
nurses were challenged prior to the
pandemic
the older people were challenged prior
to the pandemic and there's been a
desire for some time
to make public bodies more accessible to
those who had transportation
communication
or time
constraints
has the council on aging taking
advantage of the opportunities that
exist within the current law for members
to participate remotely
uh thank you for the question um and
just to clarify it's a commission on
aging
i'm sorry that's okay
it's a
it's a common uh confusion
um
we have
the challenge is for that particular
body
that there must be a quorum
physically present in a physical
location in order to take actions
so we've had
40 to 60 individuals participating
we had 11 people there in person
everybody else was on zoom but they we
we couldn't hold a vote and therefore we
couldn't take actions to move forward on
on particular recommendations that would
come to you
okay
there any other questions
seeing none thank you for your testimony
i see i have a card from representative
andres
my name is louise andrus i am from
salisbury new hampshire
i'm here as just as a citizen
the
last seven or eight years i've been to
probably every school meeting my school
district has
i have been to many town meetings just
as a citizen
uh in the last year i have probably done
so many zooms personally i'm sick of
them
if
and this bill is much to be desired
as far as let's say we had a zoom
meeting
there's people like me
i do not do video
so you have a zoom meeting
of a committee
or in your town
and names come up you have no idea who's
and in new hampshire and it's true
everywhere
not everybody has access to computers
not everybody has access
and as far as technology goes
there is much to be as desired
in some areas and i'll give an example
the other night i went to the merrimack
valley public hearing
i sat in a separate room all by myself
one the meeting started and i'm not one
to make a lot of noise
and they live stream it and i had a big
tv in front of me except nothing worked
the option was
i could go stand outside the doorway
which i did
so i could listen to the meeting but i'm
and after a while they got it fixed and
doing all these
passing something like this
people are lazy and i'm one of them it
is easier for me to sit home and do a
zoom meeting than it is to go someplace
sometimes
and be with everybody else and it's
wrong
because i enjoy other people
it's just we get into our little habits
and
there's so many also in this this bill
as far as
meetings go new hampshire was built
on public meetings and public bodies and
when a person runs for an office
they know
that they got to go to public meetings
and
to have zoom or a live stream
for people
to sit home and they want to watch it
that's one thing
but to have remote
meetings and we all just get on the
phone or we all just get on zoom
personally i'ma get it against it thank
you
are there any questions for the
representative
i just have two more cards after that
i've assumed that you'd want this since
this is our last hearing you'd like to
finish this hearing rather than break
and come back after lunch and
is that correct
okay
good afternoon mr chairman members of
the committee thank you very much for
hearing my testimony my name is tom
mullins i'm the city attorney for the
city of keene and here on behalf of the
city and its various boards and
commissions and
and committees
i'm also here as a member of the
southwest region planning commission i'm
the chairman of that board so i'm here
for them too and i'm here for the town
of peterborough trustees i had a meeting
there this morning uh in person gorham
and i'm here for them uh as well and a
couple of things i'd like to just talk
about just for a few minutes uh the
first is you know in listening to
testimony it it's pretty clear that
there's almost a disconnect
because
public bodies in the state of new
hampshire include
this august group and elected officials
but they also include like i just
pointed out
other bodies as well the southwest
region planning commission the trustees
we have an airport advisory commission
all the way to the zoning board we have
about 200 people
that sit on these various boards and
commissions they're all volunteers
uh and uh unfortunately many of them and
i'm starting to be in that category have
the color hair that i have you know we
have a lot of people who when they
retire or otherwise because they are
able to do it
basically run the city you know they run
all of these boards and commissions
and what this bill is attempting to do
and i'm not going to tell you that it
couldn't be improved i think it could be
improved some but what it's attempting
to do really is to recognize that we
have these folks out there
and that they really do need us to
accommodate
their abilities to participate in
government you know we talk about
transparency
i think we had far more transparency in
a lot of ways when we did this during
the pandemic we were able to ramp this
program up uh not i'm not going to tell
you seamlessly anybody who started this
knew at the very beginning that there
were issues and problems we were able to
overcome all of those problems
we did it both electronically and we did
it by telephone uh the executive order
emergency order that came out made no
reference at all to the telephone
contact we recognized that we shouldn't
be charging people
to attend by telephone so the city of
keene implemented an 800 number for
people to call because it's true not
everybody uh has a you know
costless phone program so we did that we
were able to put the zoom capability
into place you know and keeping in mind
that this bill just provides for that it
doesn't say that you have to do that but
we were able to do that
uh were there people who participated
from timbuktu yes there were
and you know we just sort of had to deal
with that but most people that
participated
were from the local community and really
appreciated the opportunity
to have that
to have that opportunity in order to
participate
um
you know in terms of uh
you know the idea of elected versus
appointed officials i think elected
bodies really need to consider carefully
uh if they're going to even implement
this possibility but remembering it is
that a possibility it's not something
that they have to do at this point
my members of the library board of
trustees quite recently because we as
many of you know there was a fairly big
spike over in cheshire county and in the
keene area
they were all very nervous
about coming together
in a quorum in one room
and approached me with this question
there was a possibility circulating out
in the
in the world about using the emergency
provision under the existing statute
to have a meeting uh and
you know my opinion basically was i'm
not sure it's to be used for that
purpose uh but
that's the level of anxiety that really
exists uh in many of our uh communities
so i would very much encourage you
on behalf of all of these others to at
least consider this possibility
i have to tell you i would be in favor
of having a physical location
requirement at least for individuals who
want to be able to attend who can't for
whatever reason attend by zoom or attend
by telephone or just like to go out i
mean we have that possibility so i mean
that would be something that i would
encourage you to do
i would also encourage you that if the
phone uh if the phone
aspect was to be included to make
specific uh requirement uh that it be
done either through an 800 number or
without charge
so that we don't have that controversy
in the future but please consider this i
think it's in the interest of the of the
state to do that
happy to take questions questions for mr
mullen
uh yes representative chase first
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question i'm really curious
about the 800 numbers this is the first
time i've heard it is it something the
town set up and anyone can use it
could you explain that to me please yes
well in a nutshell yes
the town set up the city set up through
the clerk's office uh an 800 number uh
that was able to be used
by all of the boards and commissions
i'm just quick
not familiar again with 800 numbers so
um
many people can call in at one time on
an 800 number and or is there a capacity
yes actually uh we we had a phone tree
set up so that uh when people called in
it was just like when you called into a
talk show
pretty much
you know they put you into the queue uh
and then you got called out of the queue
for that purpose
representative horrigan um well first of
all anecdotally i know an elected
official who endeavor upgraded her home
phone plan
um to have unlimited long distance
calling and she uh i think she had to
get it forgiven by uh whatever the
successor of verizon is i've lost track
of their name but uh so that is a real
problem for some people what i was going
to ask
what i raised my hand to ask about is
i know
at least one public body in my area
which was locked out of its facility
because the
organization whose meeting room they've
been borrowed
decided to keep his meeting room close
to the public after the governor rather
abruptly lifted the emergency order so
that was that an isolated incident or
have you heard of other cases like that
of public bodies which
can't physically meet in their own
location because it's no longer
that's actually more of a complicated
question than you would think
we did not but we had to scramble and
and we still do to some extent to be
able to find locations that would
satisfy the social distancing
requirements you know that we operate
under uh and that limited again the
ability of the public to come into the
meetings that was especially true in the
city council we have a 15-member city
council uh plus we have the staff that
have to attend myself the city manager
the city clerk
so once you start putting them into a
room that's
not much different than this
as you know it starts to become a
problem in order to be even able to
allow the public uh at that point to
come in so we had to make remote uh
opportunities available uh even when we
thank you are there other questions for
good afternoon
my name is lori ordolano i live in
nashua i'm vice president for new
hampshire right to know
and new hampshire right to know is
supporting this bill with amended
language and it's pretty amended from
the standpoint that we feel very
strongly that a physical location must
be maintained
we like the hybrid meeting approach for
public access and we believe there's
been a significant increase in public
and we believe this is a good thing
we would like to see this continue this
accessibility but we feel the physical
location should not be eliminated and we
feel the physical location
um
is important enough that the language
that was struck in a of the bill
we have unstruck it and we would like
attendance
to be required and if you can't be there
you have to have an explanation as to
why reasonably you can't attend for
those people who are serving in an
elected or appointed position
um
eliminating a physical location assumes
that interested citizens have access
with the technology and we know that's
not always the case and the telephonic
only means of communicating can be
problematic and i agree with the cost
issue that's been pointed out here and
the connectivity issues that are
appointed uh
afforded with both um audio and visual
capabilities
um the face-to-face interpersonal
contact and the verbal and non-verbal
cueing you get
when you have a physical location of
your elected people is
very important in understanding what's
happening in a meeting
and i can tell you just recently i went
to a meeting physically
and i watched my board and one of my
board members really winced at something
that was said in the meeting that also
made me wince and when the meeting ended
i went up to that board member and i
said
you looked uncomfortable with this
statement and i'm concerned about it as
well and they acknowledged that yes this
was a problem and here's the issue that
would never get recorded in the minutes
that body language wouldn't be
documented but i was able to
see it by being there and know that
something wasn't quite right
i attached for you the final report done
by the committee to review authorizing
governing bodies of municipalities to
hold virtual meetings that was finalized
november 1st of 2021 and representative
wolper did that report with a group of
individuals and all right to know new
hampshire thinks that was well done and
there were a lot of good points in there
on how to incorporate a virtual the
virtual aspects of a meeting
into our public process so we adopted a
lot of our positions from this
memorandum in work that was done by
committee
and
you know i can tell you
we have been using so nash was a pretty
big city and we have access to a lot of
technology we have a public tv station
that the meetings run on we've been able
to have a zoom feature for board of
aldermen meetings but shockingly there's
no zoom connection for school board
meetings
but when our elected officials those
that are uh choosing to stay on zoom
the one thing i don't like is they won't
run their
video they keep their screens dark their
video off and only their name appears on
the screen you know i really want to see
my elected officials and i know in some
instances i feel the remote location is
too relaxed for the elected body and
those who should be in front of their
public
there have been instances where members
of our board are on social media posting
live while the meeting is going on and i
personally feel that should be happening
but they're afforded that or they're
comfortable doing that because they're
so we took the bill and attached on page
two is our rendition of it and destruct
language in a we
unstruck and we believe it should be
there b we believed it should be there
um the physical location not being
required we said no to that um public
noticing of all uh meetings should be
done and taking pages right out of the
report that was done by representative
wolper
you have to provide a posting that tells
the public body how to access the
meeting and if
if they aren't able to access provide a
contact number and adjourn the meeting
um
and we agreed with language each member
the language of the bill that spoke
about each member participating
electronically in a meeting required to
be open it that it needs to be heard and
the speaking needs to be
identifiable to not the public and the
members itself
the other thing we added is g which came
i believe out of the report when
community input is accepted members of
the public in attendance at the physical
location will be given priority over
remote participation participation
this is what we've been doing in nashua
anyone who comes to the chamber is
called to the microphone who's because
they actually sign up in the chamber so
the um board president calls them to the
microphone
and um
then they go through the
video folks
who can raise their hand and and phone
is complicated because you don't have a
hand raising mechanism
so those people are left to shout in at
the end i want to speak
and and then they get recognized because
so i just feel it's very important i did
a court case and i will tell you
working on a right to know court case
was a nightmare i got caught in the
pandemic the priority
um process was completely wiped out i
had 10 telephonic hearings with the
court i thought they would be videoed
but they were telephonic and they were
truly the worst experience i never got
to see the judge i didn't know what the
judge looked like for 10 months
he was oz
and you know i had no idea what was
going on
and um there were no questions being
asked everyone seemed
disengaged disconnected and i thought my
case did horribly in that format and
once i got into court and had a
face-to-face meeting
in the court my case became so much
better
so
um
i'm really hesitant to back this virtual
mode for elected people really love the
physical location and love being out
there and our our committee really
believes and feels strongly that that
yes i don't know what's in her
representative whelper the chairman so
well first of all
we had several copies they didn't make
it all around the table but more
general question is
where do we find
this memorandum uh online or the
memorandum of other final reports of
committees
representative wolfers since you
authored that i think can you explain
that
so it's my understanding that it's on
the general court website if you you can
look for study committees uh separately
from the way you look for bills but it's
uh it's an advanced search uh if you
really want one i have electronic copies
and you can certainly have a couple of
the copies that are floating around here
anyway but i got an extra one available
off the office general court website you
thank you thank you testimony today the
last card i have
is
good afternoon at this point committee
nate grays for the new hampshire
municipal association we support uh hb
1014 as written
i haven't had the opportunity to review
the
amendment proposed by uh
new hampshire right to know but
from the description it does not appear
really what this bill is trying to do is
address two
intertwined issues
which is
it's really intertwined because it's
really about the functioning of
the body itself and the issue that were
that we are hoping will be targeted
through any amendment is the quorum
requirement and that's really the issue
is boards are really struggling with
getting a quorum out of physical
location i've heard proposed today from
several witnesses that they would like
an amendment that would require a board
to still have a physical location that
the public could come to
attend
provide comment as necessary
um
and that's not something we would object
to i think most municipalities would be
perfectly fine with that um even under
existing law
and i know to a large extent even with
covid
uh
municipalities were trying to figure out
how to accommodate the public and
provide as much access as possible and
many of them did set up large rooms with
video screens and everything else
social distancing to try to make sure
the public could continue to attend
those
board meetings and body meetings
so we would not have any sort of
objection to still requiring a physical
location
really what we're hoping gets
relaxed is that quorum requirement at
the physical
location i'm happy to take
questions any questions
yes representative chase
thank you
thank you for taking my question
i was obviously concerned about the
quorum as well i really like everything
about this but my question to you would
be how can that be done
isn't that kind of a written is it a
robert's rule or what
having a having a quorum
how
i'm not sure but i can explain the laws
written now and what's required so so a
board can only act if it has a quorum
present and a quorum by default
would have would be a majority
um
there's no ability under the right to
know law and it specifically addresses
the idea of reassigning a quorum to be
less than a majority and you can't do
that so you have to have a majority of
the members physically present
so
as written the law says accept in an
emergency
basically a majority have to be at the
physical location and so an emergency
has a definition under the statute
and the definition is something that
requires immediate and undelayed action
so think of something like the july
rainstorms that washed out main street
for some municipalities in the southwest
obviously their select boards need to
meet as soon as possible to get the ball
rolling on putting up signs and you know
preventing people from getting hurt
that's an emergency that's clearly an
emergency
um you know if
you know one select board members in
florida
one's on one side of the washout one's
on the other they can't physically meet
with a quorum because you're gonna have
to have two in the room
and that's just physically not possible
so that's what exists now under the law
the problem that we're seeing is you
have situations where you have
things other than emergencies so
something like a planning board is
required to meet once a month by statute
and
they simply can't because they can't get
a majority of the body in the room
together but they'll have people who are
you know they work in boston they can
take an hour off work and call in
or whatever the case may be so you could
get
you know a substantial number of people
in the room as you've heard um
and uh
but you might not be able to get that
that majority in the room and that's
seeing none thank you for your testimony
today is there anyone else who wishes to
yeah you need to might use the
microphone
i was just wondering if i could
say that it looks like there will be
some kind of amendment coming
thank you
okay
with that we'll close the hearing on
house bill 1014
and i believe
no i think we're done for the day aren't
we
yeah all right
so i i think we will be in recess until
we're scheduled to meet again which is
and that will be for an executive
session and all pending
legislation
uh well and uh
for the republicans at least i could say
i know that we will have a caucus
yes
you